OF THE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE AND THE
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE WILL COME
TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS. AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
pHERE'S SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND
FACE CVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. THE NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY IN THE
CAPITAL WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGY AND AUDIOLOGY AND
HEARING AID DISPENSERS BOARD THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL. FOR INTERIOR
DESIGN CERTIFICATION THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY. AND PHYSICAL THERAPY
BOARD. WHO ALL ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR A REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID. IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASKED EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
THAT YOU USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU'RE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
A POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
UNMUTE. POLICE SELECTOR ON MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. I.
T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK
ON MUTE WHEN YOU WERE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN. AND STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU WILL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE'S. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO THE SENATE GALLERY TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHICH TO
TESTIFY. REMOTELY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. HE WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN. AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-4185 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE TWO SIX FIVE
TWO ONE EIGHT FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
FOR THE SENATE. OR THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE FOR TODAY'S HEARING
PUBLIC COMMENT MAY BE PROVIDED
ON EACH BOARD UPON THE
CONCLUSION OF QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK ONCE AGAIN.
YOU MUST MUTED DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. S. TYPICAL I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THIS
HEARING. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS. MUSIC
TODAY IS THE SECOND IN OUR
SERIES OF SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS THIS YEAR
THESE HEARINGS ALLOW FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF REGULATORY
PROGRAMS. AND TO DETERMINE
WHETHER CHANGES IN THE LAW OR IN
THEIR OPERATIONS ARE FUNCTIONS
ARE NECESSARY. WE WILL BE
REVIEWING SPECIFIC ISSUES
REGARDING THE SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGY AND AUDIOLOGY AND
HEARING AID DISPENSERS BOARD.
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
INTERIOR DESIGN CERTIFICATION.
THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY AND
PHYSICAL THERAPY BOARD. PROGRAMS
THAT ALL PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE
IN ENSURING THE EFFECTIVE
OVERSIGHT OF HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS AND DESIGN
PROFESSIONALS. WHO INTERACT WITH
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. TO ASSIST
IN THE REVIEW AND EVALUATION OF
EACH AGENCY COMMITTEE STAFF
PREPARED BACKGROUND PAPERS WHICH
IDENTIFY ISSUES AND MAKE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR EACH
PROGRAM THESE PAPERS HAVE BEEN
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITES. EVER MADE AVAILABLE TO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES. EACH
PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE A VERY
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE PROGRAM
FUNCTIONS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES WILL THEN HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE ANY OTHER
ISSUES OR QUESTIONS WHICH THEY
MAY HAVE. WE WILL ALSO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM
CONSUMER GROUPS PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC FOR EACH PORTION. OF
TODAY'S HEARING. WE WERE VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE THIS HEARING
BE A JOINT HEARING WITH THE
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. IT IS
DISTINGUISHED CHAIR CHAIR MARC
BERMAN I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
YOUR BERMAN TO MAKE ANY OPENING
REMARKS THAT HE WISHES TO MAKE
SURE BERMAN THANK YOU CHAIR
OFTHE- JUST WANNA THINK THE
SENATE I THINK OUR COLLEAGUES
FOR JOINING US TODAY AND LOOK
FOR THE CONVERSATION THANKS SO
MUCH. THANK YOU SIR. WELL BEFORE
WE BEGIN WITH OUR SPEAKERS IN
THE PRESENTATIONS I WOULD LIKE
TO INVITE THOSE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO PARTICIPATE.
TO CALL IN NOW. PLEASE DIAL THIS
TOLL FREE NUMBER EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE. FOUR ONE EIGHT
FIVE WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE
THE ACCESS CODE. ONE TWO SIX
FIVE TWO ONE EIGHT. WE WILL NOW
HEAR FROM IF I MISPRONOUNCE YOUR
NAMES PLEASE LET ME KNOW I'D
HATE TO DO THAT DR MARSHA RATIO
BOARD CHAIR HOLLY KAISER BOARD
VICE CHAIR PAUL SANCHEZ
EXECUTIVE OFFICER. INJURIES
BURNS ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGY AND AUDIOLOGY AND
HEARING AID DISPENSERS BOARD.
WELCOME EVERYONE PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN RATHER
PRONOUNCED A PERFECTLY CAN YOU
HEAR ME WELL PERFECTLY PLEASE
PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY GOOD
MORNING TO YOU TOO CHAIRMAN
BERMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
AM DOCTOR MARCIA REGGIE
AUDIOLOGIST AND BOARD CHAIR OF
THE SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY
AUDIOLOGY AND HEARING AID
DISPENSERS BOARD AS YOU
MENTIONED WITH ME HERE TODAY IS
VICE CHAIR HOLLY KAISER WHO'S A
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGIST.
PASSENGERS ARE BOARDED SECOND
BOXER INJURIES BURNS OUR
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE OFFICER. AS
YOU KNOW THE BOARD SERVICE TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC BY LICENSING
AND REGULATING SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGISTS AUDIOLOGISTS AND
HEARING AID DISPENSERS WHICH
MEANS WE ARE THREE SEPARATE AND
DISTINCT PROFESSIONS WITH OUR
OWN SCOPES OF PRACTICE. AND
PROFESSIONAL SETTINGS. OUR
PURVIEW THEN IS TO SET ENTRY
LEVEL LICENSING STANDARDS
INCLUDING INSEMINATION
ACQUIREMENT THAT MEASURE THE
CANDIDATES PROFESSIONAL
KNOWLEDGE AS WELL AS CLINICAL
ABILITIES THAT ARE CONSISTENT
WITH THE DEMANDS AND
REQUIREMENTS OF ALL THREE
PROFESSIONS. SO THE BOARD
BOUNCES IT'SEDUCATION ITS
OUTREACH AND ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS
TO ENSURE THAT OUR POLICIES ARE
CURRENT AND THEN- CONSISTENT
WITH ACCEPTABLE STANDARDS OF
CARE FOR EACH OF THOSE
DISCIPLINES. NOW SOME OF YOU
KNOW WHAT OUR LICENSEES DO BUT
SOME DON'T SO I'D LIKE TO
BRIEFLY DESCRIBE- EACH AREA.
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGISTS
PROVIDE SERVICES IN THE AREAS OF
SPEECH LANGUAGE VOICE COGNITION
FLUENCY AND SWALLOWING DISORDERS
TO INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE
LIFESPAN. THEY SEE INDIVIDUALS
WHO AS A RESULT OF A STROKE OR
BRAIN INJURY OR OTHER NEUROGENIC
BECAUSE WE HAVE LANGUAGE
DIFFICULTIES THAT INCLUDE
BURBLING EXPRESSION AUDITORY
COMPREHENSION READING
COMPREHENSION AND WRITTEN
EXPRESSION THEY ALSO POVIDE
THERAPIES FOR INDIVIDUALS ON THE
AUTISM SPECTRUM. AND PROGRESSIVE
NEUROLOGIC DISORDERS AS WELL AS
THOSE WHO ARE DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING. THEY WORK IN A VARIETY
OF SETTINGS INCLUDING SCHOOLS
HOSPITALS COMMUNITY BASED.
FACILITIES AND IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE. I PER SERVICE FOR AN
WITH HEARING LOSS AND IS OR
BALANCE DISORDERS ACROSS THE
LIFESPAN. THEY PROVIDE STANDARD
DIAGNOSTIC HEARING TESTING FOR
ALL AGES THEY PROVIDE NEWBORN
HEARING SCREENINGS THEY FIT
HEARING AIDS FOR PATIENTS OF ALL
AGES INCLUDING INCENSE- THEY
DIAGNOSE TENNIS AND MANAGE IT-
THEY PROVIDE ORAL REHABILITATION
AND OCCASIONALLY INTRAOPERATIVE
NEUROMONITORING. AND THEY ALSO
WORK IN A NUMBER OF PROFESSIONAL
SETTINGS INCLUDING HOSPITALS.
PEDIATRIC CLINICS UNIVERSITY
HOSPITAL CLINICS PRIVATE
PRACTICE MILITARY FACILITIES AS
WELL AS IN OUR INDUSTRY RESEARCH
IN FORENSIC SETTINGS. HEARING
AID DISPENSERS PROVIDE SERVICES
TO INDIVIDUALS WITH HEARING
LOSS. INCLUDING SELECTING AND
FITTING HEARING AIDS AND PROVIDE
HEARING TEST FOR THE PURPOSES OF
GETTING AND SELLING HEARING
AIDS. AND THEY WILL ALSO WORK IN
A VARIETY OF SETTINGS INCLUDING
HEARING AID CLINICS MEDICAL
OFFICES AND RETAIL LOCATIONS.
MONITORING THE LEVEL OF
EDUCATION AND EXPERIENCE IS
CRITICAL TO THE POTENTIAL FOR
SIGNIFICANT HARM. TO CONSUMERS
IN THESE PROFESSIONS I'D LIKE TO
GIVE YOU JUST A FEW EXAMPLES.
EACH LANGUAGE WITH PAGE ARE RISK
OF ASPIRIN OF MATERIAL INTO
THEIR LUNGS WHEN UNDERGOING
EVALUATION THAT REQUIRE THE
INTRODUCTION OF MATERIALS INTO
THE THROAT. HEARING TESTING AND
EVALUATION INVOLVES THE USE OF
SOUND AIR PRESSURE AND OTHER
PHYSICAL STIMULI. IN THE EAR
INTO THE HEAD OF THE AUDIOLOGY
PATIENTS ARE AT RISK OF PHYSICAL
HARM SUCH AS PUNCTURES ON THE
SKIN OF THE EAR THE EAR CANAL
AND EARDRUM ITSELF- IF AUDIO
LOGICAL OR MIDDLE YOUR
MEASUREMENTS ARE PERFORMED
INCORRECTLY. SINCE AUDIOLOGIST
INSERTED VARIETY OF INSTRUMENTS
INTO THE EAR CANAL. OUR PATIENTS
WITH- OF HEARING AID DISPENSERS
COULD SUFFER DAMAGE TO THEIR
EARS CENTRAL TUSCANY OR
IMPRESSION TAKING IS PERFORMED
INCORRECTLY. THE BOARD'S
LICENSING POPULATION IS OVER
THIRTY FIVE INDIVIDUAL
INDIVIDUALS AND ENTITIES AND THE
US DEPARTMENT OF LABOR- SAYS
THAT THE SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGY AND AUDIOLOGY
PROFESSIONS WILL INCREASE FROM
16229% FROM TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THIRTY. AND HISTORICALLY
THE RATES OF GROWTH FOR
CALIFORNIA BEEN EVEN HIGHER THAN
THE NATIONAL RATE. SO THAT'S
CALIFORNIA'S DEMAND FOR SPEECH
AND HEARING SERVICES WILL
CONTINUE TO GROW IN THE COMING
YEARS DUE TO THE CROSS GROWING
NEED IN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. HEARING LOSS DETECTION
VIA THE NEWBORN HEARING
SCREENING PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA
AND DUE TO SIMPLY INCREASING
AGING POPULATION WHICH WILL
EXPERIENCE HEARING LOSS SUFFER
STROKES HAVE COGNITIVE DECLINE
AND OTHER DEBILITATING
ILLNESSES. THAT THAT WILL AFFECT
THEIR ABILITY TO SPEAK SWALLOW
HEARING COMMUNICATE. SO THIS
CONSUMER DEMAND WILL MAKE THE
ROLE OF THE BOARD EVEN MORE
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THE SAFETY
AND EFFICACY OF THE USE OF THREE
PROFESSIONS. SO IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE PROTECTING THE
CONSUMERS OF SPEECH AND HEARING
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
RECOMMEND THE CONTINUED
REGULATION OF THE PRACTICES OF
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY
AUDIOLOGY AND HEARING AID
DISPENSERS BY THE BOARD. WE
WOULD BE PLEASED TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU DR- MISS KAISER MS BURNS
MISTER SANCHEZ ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS. NONE OF THIS TIME BUT
WE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE HERE. THANK
YOU LET'S- LET'S TURN THE MATTER
OVER TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES IN THE CHAMBER- ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS FIRST A CHAIR BERMAN.
THANK YOU- TEAR OFF AND I KNOW
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
HAS BEEN SOME CONVERSATION ABOUT
SPEECH LANGUAGE SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGY AND AUDIOLOGY AIDS-
CAN. YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HOW PATIENTS HAVE BEEN HARMED BY
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY OR
AUDIOLOGY AIDS AND ROUGHLY HOW
MANY COMPLAINTS THAT THE BOARD
IS RECEIVED. IN REGARD TO SPEECH
LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY OR AUDIOLOGY
AIDS AND WIT THE NATURE OF
THOSE COMPLAINTS WERE. I CAN
SPEAK THE IDEOLOGY PORTION OF
THAT- IDEOLOGY AIDS AT THIS
POINT ARE PRETTY MUCH ALLOWED TO
DO ANYTHING IN AUDIOLOGIST CAN
DO UNDER THE SUPERVISION. OF AN
AUDIOLOGIST BUT AS I MENTIONED
IN THE POTENTIAL HARMS THAT CAN
OCCUR- AIDES THAT THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO TAKE YOUR IMPRESSIONS
WHERE THEY'RE PUTTING UP. A
MATERIAL INTO THE EAR CANAL-
THEY'RE LOOKING AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE THEY'RE- PACKING THE ST-
OUR APP OR DOING TYMPANUM ENTRY
WHICH IS THE MIDDLE YOUR
MEASUREMENT BOTH OF THOSE COULD
CAUSE HARM TO THE EAR CANAL. AND
TO THE- TO THE EAR DRUM.
PUNCHING THE AIR DRUM IS NOT A
GOOD THING. SO THOSE THINGS CAN
DEFINITELY OCCUR. I HAVE THOSE
THINGS OCCURRED DO WE HAVE ANY
EXAMPLES OF THOSE THINGS
HAPPENING- THAT. DANNY
CALIFORNIANS YEAH IN REALITY WE
HAVE NOT RECEIVED COMPLAINTS. OF
AUDIOLOGY AIDS HARMING-
CONSUMERS AT THIS POINT- BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN IT CAN'T
HAPPEN AT ANY TIME OR THAT IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN- BUT WE HAVE WE
HAVE TO BE WARY THAT IT COULD
ESPECIALLY THESE ARE ON.
INEXPERIENCED INDIVIDUALS
UNTRAINED UNEDUCATED MEN IN MANY
CASES. AND THEY'RE BEING GIVEN A
GREAT RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THESE
KINDS OF THINGS ANDERSON THANKS
AND CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE BOARD'S RECOMMENDED
RENEWAL AND CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS. AND HOW THE BOARD
CAME TO THAT RECOMMENDATION. FOR
AUDIO AIDS OR IN GENERAL. FOR
THE- LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY THE
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY AND
AUDIOLOGY IT'S- OKAY- THE
RESERVE POLICY WANT TO TAKE THAT
QUESTION. YES I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS BUT SO
BASICALLY THE- SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGY AND AUDIOLOGY AID
REGISTRATION IS A REGISTRATION
OF THE SUPERVISOR'S SUPERVISOR
IS TELLING THE BOARD THAT THIS
PERSON IS HELPING THEM AND
ASSISTING THEM WITH. VARIOUS
FUNCTIONS OF THE OFFICE. WITH
THE REGISTRATION IS THAT IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR THE BOARD TO KEEP
TRACK OF THE NUMBER OF AGENTS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY REGISTERED IN
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T HAVE A
RENEWAL CYCLE- I'M THERE. D.
EIGHT DESIGNATION ALSO RELIES ON
TREATY SO INITIALLY THE
SUPERVISOR TOLD THE BOARD THE
TYPE OF TRAINING THAT'S PROVIDED
TO THE BOARD IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ASSURING THAT THAT TREATING IS
ADEQUATE FOR THAT B. AND FOR THE
TASKS THAT THEY'RE ASSIGNED TO.
IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT TO DO THIS
WITHOUT A RENEWAL- PERIOD AND
IT'S ALSO DIFFICULT FOR US TO
ENSURE THAT THERE COULD THE NEST
TRAINING NOT JUST TO DO THEIR
JOB BUT YOU KEEP UP WITH THE
CHANGES THAT ARE HAPPENING IN
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY AND
AUDIOLOGY. AND IT ACTUALLY COULD
COST US MORE JUST TO KEEP THEM
REGISTERED AND CONSTANTLY HAVE
TO TRACK THEM USE WORKAROUNDS IN
OUR SYSTEM SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR IS THAT THE B. REQUIRED TO
JUST RENEW TO KEEP THE BOARD UP
TO DATE WITH THE NUMBER OF EIGHT
SO WE HAVE AND PROVIDE THEM WITH
ADEQUATE TRAINING. THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU MR. THANK YOU LET
ME JUST ASK- ONE OR TWO QUICK
QUESTIONS AND THEN TURN IT OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUES- I NOTE FROM
THE BACKGROUND PAPERS THAT. THE
BOARD REPORTS THAT IT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERSTAFFED. AND
I GUESS MY QUESTION RELATES TO
THIS UNDERSTAFFING GIVEN YOUR
LICENSE FEE STRUCTURE- WHAT
OPTIONS DO YOU HAVE TO SECURE
APPROPRIATE STAFFING TO DEAL.
WITH A NUMBER OF LICENSEES THAT
YOU. HAVE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
OVERSEEING. I THINK MISTER
SANCHEZ CAN PROBABLY ANSWER THAT
BEST. THANK YOU- THE BOARD OF
FOR THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS- WAS
IN A FISCAL STRUCTURAL BALANCE-
MATTER REVENUE THAT WAS COMING
IN WAS NOT MATCHING THE EXPENSES
THE GROWING. FORWARD SO FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS- THEBOARD
HAS BEEN WORKING TO INCREASE ITS
THEMES- WE BOTH LOOKED AT ALL
OUR DIFFERENT BERRIES AND
EFFICIENCY FOR INSTANCE WE HAVE
IT HIS LICENSING WORKLOAD AND
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF A
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION. PROGRAM
WHICH MANDATES CAN ACTUALLY
ALLOW US TO CONDUCT ONLINE
LICENSING WE THINK THAT'S GOOD-
MINIMIZE OF MUCH OF THE WORK
LOAD BUT- WE WERE RECENTLY
SUCCESSFUL AND- IN GETTING OUR
REGULATIONS PROMULGATED TO RAISE
OUR FEES. FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS- WE HAVE- MUCH BETTER FINE
CONDITION AND AS YOU KNOW THE
BUT PROCESS IT'S A FEW YEARS IN
THE LAST FIVE YEARS WE'VE
ACTUALLY INCREASED OUR STAFFING
UP BY THIRTY PERCENT. AND THAT'S
STILL NOT ENOUGH BUT WE DO
ANTICIPATE THAT IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS WE CAN GROW AND HAVE
ADEQUATE STAFFING TO ADDRESS THE
WORKLOAD AND A GROWING WORKLOAD
THAT WE EXPECT. IN FUTURE. THANK
YOU ONE THAT SAME NOTE AND- HI
KNOW IT WAS SUMMONED THE
STATEMENT IN THE BACK PAPER. THE
DC IS ALMOST ENTIRELY FUNDED BY
A PORTION OF THE LICENSING FEES
PAID BY CALIFORNIA STATE
REGULATED PROFESSIONALS IN THE
FORM OF PRO RATA AND THAT
INCLUDES THE STATE REGULATED
PROFESSIONALS IN THE WITH REGARD
TO THE BOARD WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE. AND THE FURTHER STATEMENT
IN THE BACKGROUND PAPER THAT PRO
RATED AS A PORTION PRIMARILY
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
AUTHORIZED STAFF AT EACH BOARD
RATHER THAN BASED ON THE AMOUNT
OF DC ETS SERVICES PROGRAMS- ARE
UTILIZED. WHAT OPTION. IN THIS
CASE DOES THE BOARD HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE COST PRESSURES. IN IN
RAISING. THE C. A. AND OTHER-
EXPENDITURE REQUIREMENTS. THE
BORDER DRESSES COST PRESSURES
WITHIN ITS CONTROL BY
CONTINUOUSLY MONITORING ITS
CHARGER AND MAKING NECESSARY
REDUCTIONS- THAT. THAT THEY'RE
ABLE BUT THE BOARD IS ABLE TO
MAKE. AS FAR AS- PRO RATTA- WE
ARE PROBABLY AT ABOUT 20% OF OUR
BUDGET GOES TO PRO RATTA- AS YOU
KNOW WE'RE A SMALLER BOARD-
BOARD OF OUR SIZE COULD NOT.
SUSTAIN SOME OF THE PERSONNEL
BECAUSE SOME OF THE IT COSTS
THAT ARE INVOLVED SO WE RELY
GREATLY ON THE SUPPORT THAT WE
GET FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS NOT ONLY-
THROUGH- TRAINING OUR HUMAN
RESOURCES WE GET OUR OUR LEGAL
SERVICES. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
SOME THAT'S BEE. VERY IMPORTANT
LAST FEW YEARS IS C. INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT THAT WE GET
THAT'S ALLOWING US TO MOVE ON TO
A BUSINESS MODERNIZATION
PLATFORM TO BETTER SERVE OUR.
OUR CONSUMERS AND LICENSEES.
WITH YOU FOR FIRST. COLLEAGUES
FIRST SENATOR HAND I DON'T
REMEMBER WHO WAS FIRST BUT WE'LL
CALL YOU SENATOR PAN RIGHT THANK
YOU- THANK YOU TERRA- ACTUALLY
THIRD FOLLOWING UP ON THE CHAIRS
QUESTION- CAN- HE ASKED ABOUT
THE DCA A PRO RATTA- AND OF
COURSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ALSO
YOU BEING UNDERSTAFFED AND-
NEEDING FUNDS IN YOUR RECRUITING
MORE STAFF- WHAT KIND OF
PRESSURES ARE YOU. IS THIS YOUR
BOARD EXPERIENCING FROM THE-
FEES INCREASED FEES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE- SO WE'VE
BEEN HEARING FROM MANY BOARDS
BUT I DON'T KNOW FOR YOUR
PARTICULAR BOARD- THE FEES FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAVE
COMPOSED OF ACTUALLY RAISED- IS
THAT IMPACTING YOUR BUDGET AND
YOUR YOU KNOW THE RESOURCES.
THAT YOU NEED TO FUNCTION AND
HOW ARE YOU TRYING TO AND HOW
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY BEEN IN
MANAGING THOSE LEGAL COSTS THAT
THE DOJ IS. NOW HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED. THE
USER PANEL M. ANSWER THAT
QUESTION BUT YOU DO- THE- V.
EIGHT G- READINGS- DID IT CATCH
US- SOMEWHAT BY SURPRISE IN THE
INCREASES FOR US WERE ABOUT 20%
OVER THE PREVIOUS TWO YEARS- WE
DON'T HAVE. THE LARGER-
DISCIPLINARY WORK LOOK AT SOME
OF THE OTHER BOARDS HAVE SO I
CAN I CAN I THINK IT AFFECTS
EVERYONE DIFFERENTLY FOR US- WE
HAVE THE OPTION TO. REQUEST A AG
BUDGET AUGMENTATION IN THE
MIDDLE HERE THAT'S ACTUALLY. A
FEATURE THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN
AVAILABLE TO US. BECAUSE IT ANY
CASE- KITTEN CAN COST YOU MORE
MONEY YOU CAN HAVE. TWENTY CASES
IN YOUR IN ONE CASE CAN CAN HAVE
A SIGNIFICANT EFFECT ON THE WORK
FOR INSTANCE WE HAD A CASE WHERE
A RESPONDENT LICENSEE I THOUGHT
EVERY APPEAL- AVAILABLE TO HIM
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT HAD A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON OUR-
SMALLER AG BUDGET. SO WE DO HAVE
THAT ABILITY TO GET A BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS KNOWN HERE THAT
ALSO ALLOWS THE BOARD TO PROVIDE
CONTINUOUS CONSUMER PROTECTION.
ACT OKAY I JUST CUT BY THE THAT-
BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS THAT BORN
WHO BEARS THAT COST THE BUDGET
AUGMENTATION THE LICENSEES. OR
IS IT COMING FROM THE STATE.
THAT WOULD BE OUT OF THE BOARD'S
FUND. OKAY SO SET ASIDE I JUST
YOU KNOW MAKE WHERE AGAIN IT'S
THE LICENEES- SO CERTAINLY YES
YOU'RE DOING YOUR DUTY AND YOU
NEED TO DO THAT. THESE INCREASES
IN THE OJ FEES THEN EVENTUALLY
TRANSLATES INTO. HIGHER BURDENS
FOR LICENSEES WHICH OF COURSE
ALREADY HAVING TO HAVE THE
INCREASES IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE L. D. C. A. PEREIRA AND THE
INCREASED STAFF THAT YOU DO NEED
IT WHICH OF WHICH IS CERTAINLY.
LEARN ABOUT THAT- THE OTHER
QUICK QUESTION I HAVE ON C. E.
N. O. WAS ASKED ABOUT THE AIDS
BUT- OVERALL AND YOU CONTINUE TO
CATION THAT ISSUE NUMBER TEN.
BUT THINGS I'D MAKE NOTE IS
THAT- YOU KNOW TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NOT IT'S YOU KNOW PRE COATED.
SURE THERE'S ONLY SO THERE'S
ABOUT SEVENTY EIGHT COMPLETE
PERCENT COMPLIANCE SO THAT MEANT
THE PROXY 22% OF LICENSEES WERE
COMPLIANT WITH THE C. E.
REQUIREMENTS- AND YOU'RE SIMPLY
ABOUT 5% RANDOM AUDITS BUT IF
THAT'S THE SAMPLE YOU STILL
GETTING TWENTY TWO PERCENT. I
CAN YOU SPEAK TO WHAT THE- BOARD
IS DOING TO ASSURE THAT
LICENSEES ARE ACTUALLY
MAINTAINING THE COMPETENCE. AND
THE KEEPING UP WITH THEIR C. E.
THE CONTINUING EDUCATION THANK
YOU. YES SANCHEZ MISPRINTS YOU
WANNA ARBOR DRESS THAT. I WOULD
LIKE TO DO YEAH TO TALK ABOUT
THE- I'M I'M GETTING A NEW
MESSAGE ON MY SCREEN SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE YOU CAN HEAR ME.
WE CAN HEAR YOU CAN HEAR YOU
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU YES THE
NUMBERS THAT WE REPORTED ON OUR
LAST LICENSING AUDIT WERE ACTUAL
NUMBERS SO. WE DID AN INITIAL
AUDIT AND- THAT INITIALIZE
SHOWED THAT APPROXIMATELY 20% OF
THOSE AUDITED WERE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE- WITHIN THIRTY DAYS.
70% OF THE 20% CAME INTO
COMPLIANCE SO NOW BUT I HAVE
BEEN ACTUALLY. OKAY MAY I
CLARIFY IS THAT YES YOU NOW YOU
FIRST IDENTIFY 20% AND OF THE
PEOPLE YOU IDENTIFIED. OF COURSE
AND THEY RESPONDED BUT THE YOU
KNOW YOUR TEST YOUR YOUR
SAMPLING 5% SO THAT MEANS THE
OTHER 95% HOW DO GOOD IT ARE
THEY RESPONDING I GUESS THAT YOU
KNOW THEY'VE BEEN CITED YET SO
ARE THEY HAVEN'T BEEN IDENTIFIED
SO HE CLEARLY DOES A BASELINE
PROBLEM WHEN YOU DO YOUR SAMPLE
5% AND 20% ARE DOING OR C.
REQUIREMENTS. YEAH THAT'S A
SAMPLE OF- YOUR YOUR TOTAL
POPULATION SO THAT MEANS. THE
INDEXER CONCERNING THAT SO HIGH
IN YOUR SAMPLE. YES YES YES YES
SIR BUT IF I COULD SWIM WE HAVE
A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT ISSUES
WHAT IS OKAY WE NEED ADDITIONAL
STAFFING TO CONDUCT THE C. ARTS.
CURRENTLY WHEN YOU CONDUCT A C.
ON IT OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW 5% IS A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF YOUR
ENTIRE POPULATION THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND. BUT WE ARE LOOKING TO
YOU KNOW AS PART OF BUILDING OUR
FISCAL STRUCTURE AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH REVENUE TO
CHOOSE- ADDRESS WORKLOAD WE ARE
LOOKING TO. AUGMENT OUR STAFFING
SO THAT WE COULD PROVIDE SHE
AUDITS AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WAYS THAT EVERYONE IN THE LIFE
CYCLE OF DEVICES WOULD IT SIMPLY
BE AUDITED. BUT I DID WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT. THE REASON THAT
SOME OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS WERE
OUT OF COMPLIANCE IT VARIES AND
I THINK IT HAD A LOT TO DO WITH.
THE WAY THAT OUR REGULATIONS ARE
WRITTEN THEY CAN BE SOMEWHAT
CONFUSING FOR INSTANCE MANY
AUDIOLOGISTS AND SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGIST OR TO A LICENSE
HOLDERS. AND SOME AUDIOLOGIST-
HOLD A LICENSE THAT REQUIRES
RENEWAL EVERY YEAR SO THERE WAS
SOME CONFUSION WHEN I ACTUALLY
SPOKE TO THESE- THESE
INDIVIDUALS SOME OF THEM
COMPLETED THEIR OR- THEIR C. E.
BUT THEY DIDN'T DO IT WITHIN
THE- RENEWAL PERIOD. BUT INSTEAD
DID IT WITHIN THE CALENDAR YEAR
WHAT ARE SOME OF THEM GOT THEIR
CD FROM THE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THINKING THAT IT WAS THAT MANY
OF OUR LICENSEES WORK IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SOME OF THEM
THOUGHT THAT THEIR CD WAS
ACTUALLY APPROVED CD ONLY TO
FIND OUT THAT IT WASN'T. OR THEY
TOOK SELF STUDY AND EXCEEDED THE
AMOUNT OF SELF STUDY. SO A VERY
SMALL PORTION OF THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT WE TALKED TO ACTUALLY JUST
BLEW IT OFF AND ON AND I THINK-
THE THOSE INDIVIDUALS WERE WERE
CITED. OKAY AND GIVEN. I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT SOUNDS LIKE
THERE'S SOME WORK TO DO TO
PERHAPS CLARIFY THE REGULATIONS
AND EDUCATE THE LICENSEES SO
THAT- THEY CAN BE IN COMPLIANCE
RIGHT. OKAY AND THEN ACTUALLY
JUST THE ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN
THAT'S IT THE- MAY NOTE THAT-
YOU DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE EXPLICIT
AUTHORIZATION TO DISCIPLINE
LICENSEES WHO HAVE KICKBACKS. IS
THAT SOMETHING WE NEED TO ACT ON. HERE THOUGH AS THE
LEGISLATURE. WELL IT IS IT IS
THAT. UNKNOWN HOW MANY LICENSE
MAY INVITE. OF THIS PROVISION.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TWENTY
SIX PENDING INVESTIGATIONS OF
ALLEGED UNLAWFUL REFERRALS-
WHICH AS YOU MENTIONED THE BOARD
CANNOT COMMENT ON IT- AS YOU
KNOW. THE BOARD CAN'T COMMENT ON
THIS TIME BUT THE BOARD'S
JURISDICTION IS LIMITED TO THE
CONDUCT OF ITS LICENSEES- IF. IF
THERE'S A WAY FOR THIS BODY TO
HELP US. DEAL WITH THIS I'M SURE
WILL BE APPRECIATED I DON'T KNOW
IF IT. ANSWERS WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK TO THAT FURTHER. YES AND I
APPRECIATE THIS QUESTION BECAUSE
THIS IS AN AREA THAT- JUST NEED
CLARIFICATION FOR INSTANCE THE
BOARD AS A PRIMARY FOR SIR OF
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
SECTION SIX FIFTY. WHICH
ADDRESSES THESE- ILLEGAL OR
INAPPROPRIATE REFERRALS. IN OUR
STATUTES IT LISTS THAT
PROFESSIONAL CONDUCT IT IS A
CONVICTION OF BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE SIX FIFTY SO IN
TALKING TO OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL
PARTNERS IN ON THIS ISSUE THEY
MADE A POINT THAT WE SHOULD SEE
. THE STATUTORY CHANGED TO MAKE
UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT A
VIOLATION AT SIX FIFTY AND NOT
LIMITED TO A CRIMINAL CONVICTION
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR
PANCER LATER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST WANT TO THANK ALL
OF THE LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY AND
AUDIOLOGIST- I GOT MY DEGREE A
VERY LONG TIME AGO IN
COMMUNICATIVE DISORDERS AND I
JUST REALLY REALLY APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU DO FOR FOLKS YOUR
PROFESSION IS CHANGING LIVES
EVERY DAY- BUT TALKING ABOUT ME
GETTING MY DEGREE I EVER HAD A
LONG TIME AGO I'M JUST WONDERING
IF THE AUDIOLOGY LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS SHOULD BE UPDATED
TO REFLECT CURRENT EDUCATIONAL
AND PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE
STANDARDS. THANK YOU SIR LABOR.
TEAM BAYLISS. I'M HAVING TO
RESPOND TO THAT- THANK YOU THERE
IS A NEED TO UPDATE THE
STANDARDS IN THAT- THEY'RE VERY
OLD AND THEY WERE BASED ON THE
AT A TIME WHEN WE HAD A MASTER'S
DEGREE AS THE ENTRY LEVEL DEGREE
FOR LICENSURE FRIDAY LG BUT NOW
IT IS A CLINICAL DOCTORATE AND
THAT MEANS THAT OUR NUMBER OF
CLINICAL OUR REQUIREMENTS ARE
ARE VERY LOW THERE THREE FIFTY
WHEN MOST PROGRAMS AG PROGRAMS
NOW- ARE REQUIRING AT LEAST
EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
FIFTY HOURS. ALSO WE HAVE A
RADIO AT WE HAVE IN OUR
REGULATIONS AND OUR STATUTE
THAT- THAT STUDENTS HAVE TO EARN
THE TWELVE MONTHS OF REQUIRE
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE POST
DIDACTIC SO ONCE THEY COMPLETE
OTHER COURSE WORK AND THEY HAVE
TO DO THIS THAT'S CAUSING AT ALL
OF OUR WORK WITHIN THE LAST YEAR
WITH THE VARIOUS CD PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE HAS SHOWN
US THAT THAT'S CAUSING A BIG
PROBLEM FOR STUDENTS EITHER
THOSE WHO COME FROM OUT OF THE
COUNTRY WHO HAVE ELEVEN MONTHS
VISAS WHO CAN'T COMPLETE THIS.
SOME STUDENTS ARE FINISHING WAY
BEFORE IN TERMS OF COMPLETING
THEIR HOURS AND HAVE TO CONTINUE
IN THE PROGRAM PAYING TUITION
NOT WORKING AND SO ON SO WE'RE
DEFINITELY WORKING ON BOTH THE-
REGULATORY AND STATUTORY CHANGES
TO TRY TO MAKE THAT MORE TENABLE
GET PEOPLE OUT AND. AND- WORKING
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. VERY GOOD
IF THERE'S A WE CAN DO TO HELP
WITH THAT BECAUSE WE DO KNOW
THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF PAUL
THOUGHT LANGUAGE PATHOLOGISTS
AND- AUDIOLOGISTS. PLEASE LET US
KNOW. I WOULD LIKE TO ASK COLLIE
AND- A KAISER TO SPEAK TO THE
SPEECH PATHOLOGY A SITUATION.
MA'AM YOU'RE ON MUTE. I DO IT
ALL THE TIME OKAY I THOUGHT IT
WAS A NICHE- DOCTOR ROGER DO YOU
WANT ME TO SPEAK TO IT THAT
SHORTAGES I WENT I WOULD YOU
KNOW WHAT AND WHAT WHAT KINDS OF
INTERVENTIONS HAVE HAVE BEEN
DONE OR WILL BE DONE TO TRY TO-
SOLVE THAT OKAY. WITH THE
SHORTAGE OF SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGISTS IT'S DEFINITELY
THOUGHT NATIONALLY AND EVEN MORE
SO AND- WESTERN STATES AND- AT
AT THIS SPEECH PATHOLOGIST- IN
BOTH SCHOOLS AND HEALTH CARE
SETTINGS REPORT AT THEIR JOB
OPENINGS ALWAYS EXCEED THE
NUMBER OF JOB SEEKERS- KNOWING
THAT THIS IS DUE TO IT TWO
DIFFERENT MAINLY TO DIFFERENT
FACTORS- IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT I'M PART OF IT IS THAT A
LIMITED NUMBER OF GRADUATE
SCHOOL OPENINGS. AND THE OTHER
ASPECT IS INCREASED NEED FOR
SERVICES AND AS MENTIONED WE
PROVIDE SERVICES ACROSS THE AGE
SPAN SO YOU HAVE GROWTH IN THE
AREA OF- CHILDREN BEING SEEN IN
DIAGNOSED AT YOUNGER AGES SO WE
HAVE A LOT OF EARLY INTERVENTION
SERVICES- INCREASES AND ARTISAN
WHICH WERE. AWARE OF EACH AND
THEN INCREASES IN OUR AGING
POPULATION WITH DEMENTIA
STROKES- SWALLOWING DISORDERS-
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE A LOT OF
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
THAT WITH THE NEED FOR BILINGUAL
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGISTS FAR
ACTS OUT AT EXCEEDS ON ANY WE
CAN SUPPLY- END IN ADDITION OUR
ROLE IN SCHOOLS WHERE THE
MAJORITY OF OUR SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGISTS WORK- ART OUR- OUR
SCOPE OF PRACTICE HAS EXPANDED
OVER THE YEARS WE'RE NOT. JUST
PULLING KIDS OUT INTO A CLINICAL
ROOM WE'RE WORKING IN THE
CLASSROOMS WERE SUPPORTING TEAMS
THAT ARE WORKING WITH KIDS- EVEN
INCH- GENERAL EDUCATION- SO. AS
OUR EYES ARE WORKING. THE ANSWER
IS ARE WE CLOSING ARE STRETCHED
THEN- I KNOW INTO OF END A
QUESTION ABOUT- HOW WE'RE
SOLVING IS. I IT'S A KIND OF
DANCE OF COURSE- ONE THING I
PERSONALLY INVOLVED WITH IS
LOOKING AT AT AT ELIGIBILITY- IN
CASE LOAD WORKLOAD ISSUES TO
MAKE SURE THAT. WE ARE WORKING
AT THE TOP OF OUR FIELD MAKING
SURE THAT AGAIN WE'RE NOT JUST.
PULLING KIDS IN FOR DIRECT
TREATMENT ALL THE TIME THAT THE
MORE PEOPLE WILL BE IMPACTED
THROUGH- TEAM TRAININGS USING
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY
ASSISTANTS EFFICIENTLY ALL OF
THOSE WAYS ARE GOING TO HELP US-
BE MORE EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
IN OUR SERVICES. AT THE SAME
TIME I KNOW THAT UNIVERSITIES
ARE WORKING VERY HARD ON- TRYING
TO INCREASE. IT TO INCREASE THE
PROGRAMS. I'D LIKE TO ALSO ADD
THAT LAST YEAR THE- CHANCELLOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA- STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM DID GET. A
THREE MILLION DOLLAR GRANT TO A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT AND SPEECH
PATHOLOGY MASTER'S PROGRAMS TO
TRY TO INCREASE OUR THE
ENROLLMENT. AND SO IN OUR
PARTICULAR PROGRAM WHERE I AM
HONORED TEACH- WE WERE ABLE TO
GO FROM THIRTY TWO GRADUATE
STUDENTS TO FIFTY- SPEECH
PATHOLOGY GRADUATE STUDENTS BUT
ONCE THOSE FUNDS ARE. ARE AND-
YEAH COMPLETE ERROR ARE USED AS
THEN WE'RE BACK TO OUR THIRTY
TWO THIS YEAR FOR EXAMPLE. THE
OTHER ISSUE FOR AG PROGRAMS IS
THAT. THEY THEY ONLY TAKE IN
ABOUT TEN TO TWELVE EIGHTY
STUDENTS PER COHORT. BECAUSE OF
THE WAY THE MODEL WORKS IS ONCE
YOU COMPLETE DIDACTIC SEAT THEN
YOU HAVE TO GO OUT AND DO KIND
OF LIKE A RESIDENCY. AND THAT
REQUIRES PLACEMENTS IN PUBLIC
FACILITIES HOSPITALS CLINICS AND
SO ON. AND THOSE ARE LIMITED AND
WHERE WE CAN PLACE THEM SO WE
CAN'T BE TAKING IN COHORTS OF
FORTY STUDENTS EVEN THOUGH THERE
IS THAT KIND OF INTEREST OUT
THERE- THERE'S JUST NO WHERE TO
PLACE THEM LATER AND THAT'S TRUE
FOR SPEECH PATHOLOGY AS WELL. SO
WE'RE LIMITED IN HOW MANY WE CAN
TAKE- SO STUDENTS WORK ARE
CREATIVE AND THEY END UP AND
GOING TO OTHER STATES IF
NECESSARY OR TAKING LONGER OR
WHATEVER THEY HAVE TO DO- NOW
THIS MAY SOUND COUNTERINTUITIVE
BUT- WE HAVE WE USED TO HAVE
NINE MASTER'S PROGRAMS AND
IDEOLOGY IN THE STATE. AND NOW
WE HAVE FIVE C. AS YOU PROGRAMS
AND ONE PRIVATE AND ONE YOU SEE
A RELATED PROGRAMS- WE COULD USE
MORE PROGRAMS. ED SO THAT WE CAN
BE GRADUATING A FEW MORE PEOPLE
EVEN IF THEY HAVE TO GO TO
NEVADA OR OHIO TO GET THERE AND
THEIR CLINICAL HOURS. I'LL DO
THAT AND THEN I'LL COME. BACK TO
CALIFORNIA TO SERVICE PUBLIC.
WELL IT SOUNDS LIKE NUMBER WE
NEED TO CAN. TO SURE THE THIS
ISSUES HAVE THE FUNDING FOR
THIS- BUT NUMBER TWO MY QUESTION
IS ABOUT. DOING THERE THE TIME
LIKE AN INTERNSHIP OR WHATNOT.
CAN IT NOT BE DONE AT OUR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS ARE HIGH
SCHOOLS. OR DOES IT HAVE TO BE
DONE I DID MINE IN AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL SO WE HAVE LOTS OF
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS AND HIGH
SCHOOLS UP AND DOWN THE STATE
BUT IT IS- MAY THERE BE A NEW
REQUIREMENT NOW. KNOW WHAT I
THINK OF LIKE LITTLE- AND THIS
CASE OR SPEAK TO THAT BUT I
THINK I THINK THOSE ARE
CERTAINLY BIBLE INFUSED OPTIONS
AT THIS TIME. YES- THE THERE ARE
PLENTY OF PLACES AS YOU SAID-
ACROSS ALL THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
Q. YOU SHOULD DO YOUR REQUIRED
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE HERE
YOUR INTERNSHIP HERE- HOWEVER I
HAVE SUPERVISION MUST BE
PROVIDED EIGHT HOURS A MONTH FOR
ANYBODY IN THAT DURING THAT YEAR
SO THAT'S ONE CONSIDERATION. THE
OTHER THING IS FOR THOSE THAT
ARE- WANTING O- WORK IN THE
MEDICAL FIELD. IT CAN BE MUCH
MUCH HARDER TO FIND- INTERNSHIPS
BECAUSE THEY- AND MEDICAL STAFF
GENERALLY DO NOT HAVE. THE
CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO SUPERVISE
AS READILY AS A SCHOOL DISTRICT
WHERE- IN ONE. WAY THAT A LOT
OF- INTERNS DEAL WITH THIS IS
THEY DO THEIR INTERNSHIPS IN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND LATER ON TO
SWITCH OVER TO MEDICAL- IN THEIR
PRACTICE BUT IDEALLY THAT IS NOT
WORKING WITH- CHEESE. GOT IT
THANK YOU LADIES VERY MUCH KEEP
UP THE GREAT WORK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU CENTER
LEVEL OF SPIRITUAL LET ME JUST-
BEFORE YOU START LET ME JUST ASK
A COUPLE FOLLOW UP MAY I. THANK
YOU SIR- WHAT IS THE DELTA IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF JOBS THAT
REMAIN UNFILLED. AND THE NUMBER
OF SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY.
THE PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE
COMING OUT OF THESE TRAINING
PROGRAMS. MAYBE I MISSED IT DO
YOU HAVE THAT NUMBER. WELL WE
KNOW WHAT THE GROWTH RATE WILL
BE BUT WHAT WE DON'T KNOW FOR
SURE DO IT TRACTION AND OTHER
ISSUES- EXACTLY HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO BE- GRADUATING AND
THE NEW EIGHTY PROGRAMS AT LEAST
FOR AUDIOLOGY- YOU MAY KNOW THAT
THAT SET A NEW PROGRAM STARTED
IN CALIFORNIA IN THE CSU ABOUT
FOUR YEARS AGO. SO ONLY THE
FIRST COHORT IS BEING GRADUATED
FROM CAL STATE LA NOW AND THIS
SUMMER WILL GRADUATE THE FIRST
COHORT- BUT THE NEED IS GOING TO
GROW SIGNIFICANTLY FOR BOTH
PROFESSIONS AND I JUST FEEL LIKE
NATIONWIDE THE SHORTAGE IS VERY
OBVIOUS- THERE ARE MANY PAPERS
OUT THERE THAT THAT I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO SUPPLY YOU WITH THOSE
REFERENCES. AND SHOW WHAT THE
EXPECTED SHORTAGES ARE GOING TO
BE BUT WE DON'T KNOW THE EXACT
NUMBERS OF WHAT THE COURT SIZE
WILL BE ACROSS THE STATE AND
TELL ALL ALL PROGRAMS START
PUTTING OUT THERE THERE ARE TEN
TO TWELVE GRADUATES EACH YEAR
WHAT WE HAVE MAYBE FIFTY TO
SIXTY DO AUDIOLOGISTS AND THAT
HASN'T HAPPENED. I KNOW THAT
SOUNDS A STATE FOR EXAMPLE ONLY
TOOK IN SIX LAST YEAR- FOR
VARIOUS REASONS- SO WE CAN
ALWAYS COUNT THE COHORT PLAN.
ANYWAY THAT'S THAT'S HOW I LOOK
AT IT AND THAT'S FOR AUDIOLOGY I
ASSUME YES IN THE END THE
TERMINAL DEGREE FOR AUDIOLOGIST
AS IT IS A DOCTORAL DEGREE IT'S
A CLINICAL DOCTORAL TRAINING AND
DOCTORAL DEGREE AND FOR SPEECH
LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY IS MORE
APPARENT FROM THE PRIOR
TESTIMONY TO. THE PROFESSIONAL
DEGREE OUTSIDE OF. TEACHING IS A
MASTER'S DEGREE. YEAH I AM WELL
IT IT IS A- YOU DON'T NEED TO
HAVE A TEACHING. CREDENTIAL IN
SCHOOLS YOU CAN WORK WITH THE
CREDENTIALS OR A LICENSE. AND
THE REASON AND THE REASON I ASK
MY QUESTION ABOUT THE DELTA.
MEMBERS I THINK YOU MENTIONED
THAT THERE WERE MORE JOBS THAN
THERE WERE PEOPLE TO FILL THEM.
AND I DIDN'T KNOW IF THAT NUMBER
HAD BEEN QUANTIFIED. I HAVE
INFORMATION FROM SURVEYS FROM
THE AMERICAN SPEECH LANGUAGE
HEARING ASSOCIATION- DID YOU.
SURVEYS ARE OF THOSE IN
HEALTHCARE AND THOSE IN A SCHOOL
BASED AND- I'M SURE WE CAN GIVEN
MORE TIME TO GET MORE PRECISE
INFORMATION BUT- IN SO. ONE OF
THE MORE RECENT. REPORTS IS IT'S
NOT- IN ITS TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN MORE THAN- WELL 64% TO
MORE THAN HALF OF SCHOOL BASED
SLP A SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGIST- REPORTED THAT
THEIR- SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE ARE.
SEEKING SPEECH LANGUAGE.
PATHOLOGIST AND IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN- THE HEALTH CARES
SURVEY SHOWED THAT- THOSE
RESPONDED 27% OF THEM. SAID THEY
WERE FUNDED UNSEALED- POSITIONS
IN THEIR SETTINGS BUT WITH
RESPECT TO THE PIPELINE I
ASSUME. THE PURPOSE THE PIPELINE
STARTS AT THE TRAINING PROGRAMS
WHICH I ASSUME ARE LARGELY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
PROGRAMS IS THAT CORRECT. THAT
IS CORRECT TEN IN TERMS OF
CAPACITY IN THE PROGRAMS IS THIS
SITUATION SIMILAR TO- FOR
EXAMPLE NURSING TRAINING
PROGRAMS WHERE THE LIMITING
FACTOR TENDS TO BE ONE THE
AVAILABILITY OF PHD FACULTY TO
TEACH AND TO THE AVAILABILITY OF
CLINICAL TRAINING SLOTS. I SAID
IT'S MORE THE LATTER- WE'RE NOT
REALLY HAVING DIFFICULTY FINDING
FACULTY- BUT IT'S THE BEING ABLE
TO PLACE PEOPLE FOR THEIR
EXTERNSHIP- A CLINICAL
EXPERIENCES IS THE BOTTLENECK.
ESPECIALLY MEDICAL FACILITIES.
OKAY CIRCLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SEARCH LOADING YEAH THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND- THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION EXTREMELY%
INFORMATIVE- IDEA BOARD OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS DURING THE
PANDEMIC ADOPTED A NEW STRATEGIC
PLAN- ADDRESS SCENE- IMPROVING
SERVICES TO THE CONSUMERS
LICENSING- INCREASING OUTREACH
TO THE STAKEHOLDERS AND OF
COURSE- ENFORCEMENT OF SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS CAN YOU HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF THE POSITIVES THAT- YOU
ACCOMPLISHED AND STILL SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT YOU SAY.
THAT YOU FACE OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS- I GUESS MORE
THAN WORKERS COULD SPEAK TO THAT
ISSUE BUT- MR SANCHEZ WOULD YOU
TALK ABOUT OUR OUR MODERNIZATION
OUR BUSINESS MODERNIZATION AND-
PLANS AND EFFORTS AT THIS TIME.
YES- OBVIOUSLY- THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC CHANGED ALL OF
OUR LIVES AND THE WAY THAT WE DO
THINGS- THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
EVEN THOUGH IT CAUGHT US BY
SURPRISE I'M FORTUNATE TO HAVE.
REALLY GREAT STAFF AND GREAT
LEVEL OF SUPPORT AT DCA WITH
PROGRESSIVE TECHNOLOGY SIDE BUT
EARLY ON WHAT WE DID WAS- MY
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE OFFICER-
MISS BURNS AND I. CAME UP WITH A
COMMUNICATION PLAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE TALKING TO
STAKEHOLDERS LICENSEE. LICENSEES
THE WORK SITES TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE THAT WE UNDERSTOOD WHAT
THE NEEDS WERE OUT THERE TO
SERVE THE CRITICAL NEEDS OF THE
CHILDREN THAT MEET SOME OF THE
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE- WE
SERVE IN ELDERLY POPULATION
SURVIVING CHILDREN IN SCHOOLS
THAT'S A LARGE. A PERCENTAGE AND
THEN- ELDERLY PEOPLE SO AT SOME
POINT IN EVERYONE'S LIFE SPAN
YOU'RE GOING TO YOU'RE GOING TO
WORK WITH A SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGIST AND AUDIOLOGIST OR
HEARING AID DISPENSER IT'S VERY
LIGHT AND SO WE MADE SURE THAT
WE WERE COMMUNICATING WITH ALL
THESE- POINTS THAT- THERE MIGHT
BE PRESSURE. AND ADD A PLAN TO
ADDRESS WHATEVER NEEDS THEY
WERE- WE WORK WITH DC EIGHTY GET
WAIVERS PAST WAIVERS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO KEEP TO CONTINUE
SERVICES. AND MOBILIZE OUR OWN
STAFF WE HAVE A- A PAPER BASED
SYSTEM SO WE HAD TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY SINGLE PERSON HAD
ACCESS TO WORK FROM HOME. JUST
LIKE THE WORK IN THE OFFICE ON
THE OTHER REAL IMPORTANT THING
THAT WE DID IS WE CONDUCTED
STATEWIDE EXAM OF HEARING AIDS
SPENCER'S. IT'S A PRACTICAL
HANDS ON EXAM TYPICALLY DONE IN
PERSON. MA'AM WE ACTUALLY
SECURED A SITE. TO BRING THEM
OVER TO ACTUALLY OUR FACILITIES
AND- UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
MISS BURNS WE MADE SURE THAT
EVERYTHING MET COPE WITH
STANDARDS. THAT THAT EVERYTHING
WAS SANITIZED AND SAFE AND ARE
QUITE AN OPERATION KEEP IN
SOCIAL DISTANCING OR BEING ABLE
TO CONDUCT THESE. VERY IMPORTANT
EXAMINATIONS. THANK YOU MR.
THANK YOU SEARCH FOR THE CENTER
ADMIN THANK YOU. MR CHAIR AND I
WAS JUST IT WAS MORE OF AN
OBSERVATION BACK TO THE TO THE
LAST POINT I THINK WHEN WE
CONTINUE TO DO THE SUNSET
REVIEWS I THINK WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO SEE THE SAME ISSUE
WELL WE HAVE REALLY ENCOURAGED
INCREASED ENROLLMENT AND R. C.
ISSUES OFTEN TIMES IT HAS
RESULTED. IN THE DETERIORATION
OF MASTER'S PROGRAMS AND THE
PROLIFERATION OF MASTER'S
PROGRAMS- SO I KNOW IT SOCIAL
WORKERS NURSES AUDIOLOGISTS ALL
OF MASTER'S PROGRAMS ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE. AND SO I THINK WHEN
WE GO BACK INTO THE PROCESS
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO LOOK AT AT
NOT JUST INCREASING ENROLLMENT
BUT SPECIFICALLY FOR DEPARTMENTS
AND BECAUSE IT'S A WE'RE WE'RE
CHASING OUR TAILS IS NOT ENOUGH
TO PROVIDE THE CLINICAL
SUPERVISION AND YET WE'RE NOT
PRODUCING ENOUGH SO. JUST AN
OBSERVATION GOOD POINT THANK YOU
SIR EDMUND- COLLEAGUES ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS CENTRE PANNIER MIKE IS
UP DO YOU HAVE ANY. YOUR MIKE IS
NOW DOWN. THANK YOU MEMBERS-
WILL ACCEPT TESTIMONY FROM
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY AND
AUDIOLOGY AND HEARING AID
DISPENSERS BOARD. LET'S BEGIN
WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
GALLERY. I SEE NO ONE STANDING
UP THANK YOU LET'S NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY SUCH INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE COMMENT. WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK THANK YOU MR
SURELY THE GENTLEMAN FOR COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE'S KEYPAD AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. YOUR LINE NUMBER IS
CALLED STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION FOR THE LEGISLATIVE
WORK. ONE NUMBERS SURE WE DO
HAVE SOME QUEUING UP. THANK YOU.
ONE MOMENT SIR.
ONE TWENTY LINES OPEN WITH
POLICE. THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ANDREA BALL
HAPPENED TO CALIFORNIA EACH
HEARING LINE SPEECH LANGUAGE
HEARING ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
FOR THE THROWBACK CONVERSATION
FIRST HE HAD EIGHTY EIGHT THE
COURT THE CONTINUED LICENSING
AND REGULATION BY THE BOARD AND
APPRECIATE THE BOARD. OUTREACH
ESPECIALLY DURING THE CALL THE
PANDEMIC WE PROVIDED MORE
DETAILED COMMENTS IN A LETTER
THAT WE SENT OUTLINING RESPONSES
AND COMMENTS ON ISSUES OUTLINED
IN A VERY WELL THE LORD AT
REPORT. TO I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT ONE INTERNET RESOURCES
TO ALLOW THE BOARD TO UPDATE
THEIR TECHNOLOGY AND THEIR
WEBSITE AND THEY'RE LIKE TRONIC
COMMUNICATION CRITICAL NOT ONLY
FOR LIFE YOU KEEP THAT OFF THE
FRONT CONSUMER. THE WAY TO
RECEIVE INFORMATION AND COMPLETE
DOCUMENTATION AT IN A MORE
TIMELY MANNER WE ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
CONVERSATION ABOUT CONTINUING
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS WE DO
BELIEVE HAVING. A BROAD ACCENT.
AND PROVIDERS IT'S IMPORTANT.
AND AS THAT POINT YOU DOES COME
. FINALLY DID APPRECIATE THE WAY
- FOR PALESTINIAN AT POINTED NOW
LET. LIKE IF YOU CAN CONGRESS
WITH THAT AND BE A TELEHEALTH
EVERYTHING BY. EACH ONE
PATHOLOGY AND OUT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU MA'AM LEHRER NEXT
PLEASE. AND ONCE AGAIN FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR SURE
THERE ARE NO FOR THE COMMENTERS
ACCUSED ADDRESSED THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVING HEARD
PUBLIC TESTIMONY MEMBERS ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. ABOUT THE
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY AND
AUDIOLOGY AND HEARING AID
DISPENSERS BOARD CHAIR BERMAN
ANY FINAL COMMENTS. NO NOT
REALLY THANK YOU THANKS FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION SIR. LET'S NOT
FORGET A REVIEW OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR INTERIOR
DESIGN CERTIFICATION LET'S
WELCOME GEORGE BRAZIL BOARD
CHAIR AND ROSE SUIVI. IF I
PRONOUNCE THAT CORRECTLY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU- I WANT TO
START BY SAYING THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN THE
LEGISLATIVE STAFF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE TODAY
MY NAME IS GEORGE BRAZIL AND THE
CURRENT CHAIR FOR CCC IDC I'M A
PAST PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
NORTH CHAPTER OBVIOUSLY THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF INTERIOR
DESIGNERS- I AM THE CO OWNER OF
SUBSCRIBERS ALL DESIGN HERE IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND I'VE BEEN
PRACTICING INTERIOR DESIGNERS
FOR THE FOR THE FOR THE PAST.
THIRTY YEARS- I WANTED TO START
OFF WITH A BRIEF HISTORY OF CC
IDC ON JANUARY FIRST NINETEEN
NINETY ONE CHAPTER THREE POINT
NINE SECTION FIFTY FIVE EIGHT
ZERO ZERO THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
WAS CREATED BY SENATE BILL ONE
FIVE THREE AUTHORED BY SENATOR
CRAVE AND COULDN'T FIND A TITLE
ACT FOR CERTIFIED INTERIOR
DESIGNERS. THE STATUTE LAID OUT
THE EDUCATION AND WORK
EXPERIENCE REQUIREMENTS ALONG
WITH THE YET TO BE DETERMINED
EXAMINATION FORINDIVIDUALS TO
BECOME A CERTIFIED INTERIOR
DESIGNERS AND THE DEFINITION OF
AN INTERIOR DESIGN ORGANIZATION
TO PROVIDE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
TITLE ACT PER SENATOR CRAVENS
LETTER DATED DECEMBER NINETEEN
NINETY ONE THE INTENT OF THE
FOURTH FOR THE TITLE LACKED WAS
A MEANS BY WHICH THE PUBLIC AND
LOCAL BUILDING OFFICIALS COULD
EASILY IDENTIFY. COMPETENT
PROFESSIONALS TO WORK WITH
BUILDING LIFE SAFETY
FLAMMABILITY AND DISABLED ACCESS
CODES ISSUES. FOR INTERIOR
SPACES. BUT UPON THIS ENTERED
FOR AND- DEVELOPED IN CREATED A
NONPROFIT BOARD THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR INTERIOR DESIGN CERT
CERT. MODELED AFTER STATE BOARDS
TO OVERSEE THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THIS TITLE ACT AS REQUIRED BY
THE- LEGISLATURE. THE BOARD IS
CHARGED WITH VERIFYING EDUCATION
AND EXPERIENCE REQUIREMENTS FOR
THOSE WHO APPLIED TO BECOME
CERTIFIED IN CHAIR DESIGNERS
DETERMINING AND APPROVING A
SUITABLE AND APPROPRIATE
CALIFORNIA EXAMINATION AND
MAINTAIN A DATABASE OF THOSE WHO
BECOME CERTIFIED. AS OF
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE CC
IDC HAS CERTIFIED. FIVE THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
INDIVIDUALS SINCENINETEEN
NINETY ONE OF WHICH TWO THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE ARE
STILL ACTIVE MOSTLY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. OUR MISSION IS TO
ESTABLISH AND IMPLEMENT
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS AND
EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS.
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC AND
FACILITATE INTERIOR DESIGN
PROFESSIONALS COMPLIANCE WITH
OUR STANDARDS AND CODE OF.
ETHICS IN ORDER TO PROVIDE FOR
THE PROTECTION HEALTH LIFE
SAFETY AND WELFARE OF THE PUBLIC
BY ADMINISTERING THE CERTIFIED
INTERIOR DESIGNERS TITLE ACT. AS
PART OF OUR BOARD'S MISSION WE
ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO BECOME
CERTIFIED INTERIOR DESIGNERS
MEET THE STATUTORY STANDARDS OF
COMPETENCY BY WAY OF EDUCATION
EXPERIENCE AND EXAMINATION WE
ESTABLISH THE MEASURES THE
MEASUREMENT STANDARDS OF
COMPETENCY FOR EXPERIENCE AND
EXAMINATION FOR THOSE WHO BECOME
CERTIFIED INTERIOR DESIGNERS. WE
EMPOWER CONSUMERS BY PROVIDING
INFORMATION AND EDUCATIONAL
MATERIALS TO HELP THEM MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS WHEN HIRING
AN INTERIOR DESIGN. INTERIOR
DESIGNER CERTIFIED OR OTHERWISE
AND WE EMPOWER INTERIOR
DESIGNERS BY PROVIDING
INFORMATION ON HOW TO BECOME
CERTIFIED INTERIOR DESIGNERS IN
CALIFORNIA IN ACCORDANCE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THE TITLE LAP. AND FINALLY
PROVIDING FORMS AND
PRESENTATIONS TO INTERIOR DESIGN
SCHOOL PROGRAMS STUDENTS AND
INTERIOR DESIGNERS IN GENERAL ON
THE REQUIREMENTS AND BENEFITS OF
BECOMING A CERTIFIED INTERIOR
DESIGNER. SOME OF THE CHANNEL.
M. TWO CERTIFICATION- THE
LARGEST BARRIER TO CERTIFICATION
AND OR THE INTERIOR DESIGN
PROFESSION AS A WHOLE IS THE
ISSUE OF INTERIOR DESIGNERS
BEING ABLE TO SUBMIT
NONSTRUCTURAL NON SEISMIC
INTERIOR DESIGN PLANS TO LOCAL
BUILDING DEPARTMENTS FOR PERMIT
APPROVAL AN ACQUISITION. A
PROCESS BECAUSE THEY'RE BEING
DENIED ACCESS TO THE PERMIT
PROCESS WITHOUT AN ARCHITECT OR
AN- OR AN ENGINEER STAMP.
BUILDING APARTMENTS IN LOS-ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO SAN JOSE
AND SACRAMENTO REGULARLY DENY
INTERIOR DESIGNERS THE ABILITY
TO SUBMIT NONSTRUCTURAL NON
SEISMIC INTERIOR DESIGN PLANS
FOR PERMIT APPROVAL AND
ACQUISITION FOR PURPOSES. RECENT
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE LOS ANGELES
FAST TRACK PROCESS FOR HIM IT
PROHIBITS ANYONE FROM SUBMITTING
PLANS THAT DO NOT HAVE AN
ARCHITECTS OR OR- ENGINEER
STAND. EASILY WITHOUT THE
ABILITY TO SUBMIT PLANS FOR THE
LAW BUILDING PROFESSIONAL CODE.
FIVE FIVE THREE SEVEN FIVE FIVE
THREE EIGHT AND FIVE EIGHT OH
FIVE BUILDING DEPARTMENTS ARE
CREATING BARRIERS TO
CERTIFICATION AND THE INTERIOR
DESIGN PROFESSION IN. CALIFORNIA
THESE BERRIES UP THESE BARRIERS
ARE CONSIDERED PREJUDICE IN
NATURE AND INTERIOR DESIGN
PROFESSION IN CALIFORNIA IS
LARGELY COMPRISED OF WOMEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY AND- MINORITIES.
ACCORDING ACCORDING TO DATA USA
DOT COM NCARB W. DOT COM IN THE
U. S. BUREAU OF LABOR
STATISTICS. SEVENTY SIX POINT 3%
OF INTERNET SIGNERS ARE WOMEN
COMPARED TO NINETEEN POINT 2%
WHICH AREN'T MAN. TWENTY FOUR
POINT 4% OF ARCHITECTS ARE WOMEN
COMPARED TO SIXTY EIGHT POINT 8%
WHICH ARE MEN AND 90% OF
BUILDING PROFESSIONALS. ARE
WOMEN COMPARED 283% WHICH ARE
MEANT. AND FINALLY THE LANGUAGE
CHANGES WE HAVE PROPOSED WILL
CLARIFY FOR THE PUBLIC AND
BUILDING OF THE FACIALS A SCOPE
OF WORK INTERIOR DESIGNERS HAVE
BEEN DOING OVER THE PAST THIRTY
YEARS FOR SENATORS CRAVEN'S
ORIGINAL IN INTO. AND THANK YOU
. ANYTHING FURTHER OF BEFORE I
TURN IT OVER TO QUESTIONS BY
MEMBERS IN THE CHAMBER. MS
WEAVING. HERE ON MUTE. PAULA J.
AS COMMITTEE MEMBERS LEGISLATIVE
STAFFING YES MY NAME IS ROSE
MAYBE I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CC IDC THE CALGARY COUNCIL
FOR INTERIOR DESIGN
CERTIFICATION I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION LET US
ADDRESS THE IS IT THE ISSUES
THAT WERE PRESENTED TO US IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER. FIRST THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION FOR US TO
ADDRESS HOW WE I'M- WE ARE
COMPLYING WITH THE BAGLEY KEENE
ACT. AND THE BAGLEY KEENE ACT IS
PROVIDED TO ALL OF OUR NEW BOARD
MEMBERS DURING THEIR BOARD OR
ORIENTATION MEETING IN THE BOARD
ORIENTATION. BINDER DURING THE
NEW BORDER NUMBER ORIENTATION WE
COVERED THE ACT AND THE BOARD
MEMBERS ARE ASKED TO SIGN IN AND
IT KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT THEY
HAVE RECEIVED THE BECKLEY KEEN
ACT UNDERSTAND IT. AND WILL
COMPLY WITH IT IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THEM AT THAT TIME
THAT'S WHEN IT BAGLEY KEENE ACT
AS A DRESSED WE MAKE EVERY
EFFORT DURING OUR MEETINGS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL OF THE
REQUIREMENTS FROM THE BACKLIT
SCENE ACT ARE MET- ISSUE NUMBER
TO STAMP ACCEPTANCE. AND FIRST
OFF THE TITLE LAYPERSONS-
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOT LICENSED
REGISTERED OR DESIGN
PROFESSIONALS M. C. C. A. B. C.
BELIEVES THAT CERTIFIED INTERIOR
DESIGNER DESIGNER SHOULD NOT BE
CONSIDERED IN THIS GROUP WITHIN
THE ABOVE DEFINITION. WHO
PRACTICE UNDER THE EXEMPTIONS
OF- BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
CODE FIFTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN OF
FIFTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT M. C. C.
IDEAS ARE EMBEDDED FOR EDUCATION
EXPERIENCE AND TESTED ON
CALIFORNIA CODES AND TITLE
TWENTY FOUR REGULATIONS. ALONG
WITH CALIFORNIA LAWS AND STATUES
THAT ARE RELEVANT TO INTERIOR
DESIGNERS AND HVE A SPECIFIED
AMOUNT AGAIN EDUCATION AND
EXPERIENCE- SEE IDEAS SHOULD NOT
BE CONSIDERED LAY PERSONS THEY
ARE DESIGN PROFESSIONALS. AN IT
SHOULD BE POINTED OUT. BUT THE
ONLY GROUP HAT HAS ANY SAY ON
WHO MAY OR MAY NOT SUBMIT PLANS
FOR THE PERMIT PERMITS OR THE
BUILDING OFFICIALS BUILDING
OFFICIALS ARE NOT LICENSED BY
THE STATE AND THEREFORE HAVE NO
OVERSIGHT OTHER THAN THE PURVIEW
OF THE INDIVIDUAL CITIES AND
COUNTIES THEY WORK FOR WHILE
MANY BUT IT BUILDING DEPARTMENTS
ARE CONVERSANT WITH THE C.
IDEOLOGUE AND ACCEPT NON
STRUCTURAL AND NON SEISMIC
PLANS. THERE ARE SEVERAL WHO DO
NOT BECAUSE- WHO. DELAYED
BECAUSE THEY FEEL THE ONLY
VIABLE OPTION IS TO ACCEPT PLANS
ONLY FROM. LICENSED ARCHITECTS
AND ENGINEERS. BUILDING
OFFICIALS HAVE STATED THAT IF
THE LANGUAGE IN OUR TITLE ACT
WAS CLARIFIED WITH WHAT C. IDEAS
DO THEY WOULD NOT HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH PLAN SUBMISSIONS. THIS IS
THE GOAL THAT WOULD BENEFIT THE
DESIGN PROFESSION IN CALIFORNIA
. STAKEHOLDERS MEETINGS HAVE NOT
YIELDED RESULTS DUE TO THE FACT
THAT CERTAIN PARTIES- HAVE ONLY
THEIR AGENDA IN MIND AND IT
MAKES IT DIFFICULT TO WORK WITH
FINDING A COMPROMISING SOLUTION.
CC IDC SERVES THE INTERIOR
DESIGN PROFESSION AS A WHOLE IT
IS IMPOSED ON IMPROVING PLAN
SUBMISSIONS FOR EVERYONE THAT WE
SERVE. CURRENTLY THERE ARE SEVEN
DESIGN RELATED PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS- A. I. B. T. THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF BUILDING
DESIGN WORK HAS FOUR C. ID
MEMBERS S. I. D. AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF INTERIOR DESIGNERS
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWELVE C.
EIGHTY MEMBERS TO NOTE THAT
EIGHTY NINE OF THOSE ARE
PROFESSIONAL MEMBERS HAVING
PASSED IN CA. ID Q. JUST DESIRE
SOCIETY OF AMERICA WE DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE ANY CITIES
LISTED- INTERIOR DESIGN
EDUCATION- COUNCIL WE HAVE SIX
CAT'S. WITHIN MEMBERSHIP.
INTERIOR DESIGN SOCIETY. WE HAVE
TWENTY SIX THE- INTERIOR
INTERNATIONAL FURNISHING AND
DESIGN ASSOCIATION FOURTEEN SEE
EIGHTIES. AND THE INTERNATIONAL
INTERIOR DESIGN ASSOCIATION TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT EIGHT
C. EIGHTIES ARE MEMBERS OF THOSE
HUNDRED AND SIX ARE
PROFESSIONALS. HAVING PASSED
INTO GET A Q. NKPA WHICH THE
NATIONAL KITCHEN AND BATH
ASSOCIATION OF EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHTY MEMBERS. ANY UNITED
STATES GREEN BUILDING COUNCIL
TWENTY FOUR C. ID MEMBERS WE
ALSO REPRESENT TWELVE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY ONE C. ID'S WHO DO NOT
BELONG TO ANY PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS. OF THOSE SEVENTY
FOUR OF STATE TODAY I AM
SPECIALIZE IN COMMERCIAL
INTERIOR DESIGN. OF THE TWO
HUNDRED ED TWENTY FOUR.
1-000-200-0400 SERVER INTERIOR
DESIGNERS I'M AT EIGHT HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FOUR BELONG TO ONE OR
MORE PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
THE REST ARE DO NOT BELONG TO
ANY. TWO OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS
ARE ONLY WILLING TO WORK WITH CC
IDC IF THERE IF CC IDC IS TO
GIVE IN TO DEMANDS. AS SUCH AS
ONLY USING THE MCAD Q. AS
REQUIRED THAT TEST FOR
CERTIFICATION AND ALSO REQUIRING
MORE CONTROL OF THE CC IDC BOARD
. IN STRATEGIC PLANNING A
MEETING WHERE THIS COMMERCIAL
DESIGNATION WAS CREATED LEADERS
OF BOTH OF THESE GROUPS
PARTICIPATED IN CREATING THE
GUIDELINES FOR THE DESIGNATION
AND AGREED TO IT. TWO DAYS PRIOR
BEFORE THE COMMERCIAL
DESIGNATION BEING PRESENTED TO
THE BOARD. AND A DEMAND LETTER
WAS SENT SAYING THEY WOULD ONLY
SUPPORT COMMERCIAL DESIGNATION
IF CCAD GREED. THE ONLY UC AND
C. C. R. E. Q. IN PLACE THREE
NEWPORT POSITION SMITH MEMBERS
FROM THEIR ORGANIZATION ON OUR
BOARD. CCBC BOOK AWARD REMINDED
THEM THAT EVERY ORGANIZATION HAS
EQUAL REPRESENTATION ARE ABOARD
AND THAT INEQUITIES OF THE
INSANITY Q. AS CERTIFICATION
EXAM FOR CALPERS AND- CALIFORNIA
HAVE ALREADY BEEN PROVEN. ANY
ADDITIONAL CERTIFICATION TITLE
REGISTRATION OR LICENSURE WILL
HAVE NO MERIT UNLESS THERE'S A
STRENGTHENING AND CLARIFICATION
OF THE LAW THAT IS CURRENTLY IN
PLACE. THIS TITLE WILL NOT ALLOW
ANYONE TO DO ANY MORE WORK THAN
WHAT WAS ALLOWED UNDER THE
EXEMPTIONS IN FIFTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN OF FIFTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
OF THE ARCHITECTS ACT.
REGARDLESS OF INTERIOR DESIGNERS
PRESENT CREDENTIALS OR
EXAMINATIONS THEY HAVE PASSED
THE REVIEW AND APPROVAL
CONSTRUCTION DOCUMENTS WILL
ALWAYS BE UNDER THE PURVIEW OF
THE BUILDING OFFICIAL HOLDING
THE COMMERCIAL CERTIFIED.
DESIGNER TITLE OUT TO DO SO IS
ILL ADVISED AND WOULD RESULT IN
FURTHER FRUSTRATION TO
CALIFORNIA INTERIOR DESIGNERS IN
BUILDING OFFICIALS ALIKE. AGAIN
MAY I STATE THAT THE BUILDING A
COMMERCIAL INTERIOR DESIGNERS
THERE THE SAME WITH ARCHITECTS
THERE'S NO SUCH THING IS
COMMERCIAL AND OR- RESIDENTIAL
INTERIOR DESIGNERS MAY CHOOSE
THAT PATH OF BUSINESS BUT DATE
WOULD CHANGE AS IN. WHEN THE-
CURRENT- PANDEMIC HAPPENED A LOT
OF THE INTERIOR DESIGNERS WHO
WERE PUT OUT OF WORK FOR
COMMERCIAL WENT BACK TO
RESIDENTIAL WHEN THERE WAS A-
RECESSION PREVIOUSLY IT WAS THE
OPPOSITE THERE WAS A LOT OF
RESIDENTIAL WORK SO PEOPLE
CHANGE TO COMMERCIAL SO THERE IS
NO HARD FAST I AM A CERTIFIED
COMMERCIAL JETLINER OR-
RESIDENTIAL DESIGNER. HEY HAS
SHOWN IN NO UNCERTAIN TERMS THAT
THEY WILL NOT SUPPORT THE
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE IN THE CAP
LEGISLATION. INITIALLY IT WAS
BECAUSE- OF THE ISSUE OF SAFETY
OF THE BUILDING. THEN THEIR
CONCERN CHANGED TO THE NEW
DESERT DEFINITION OF SEISMIC WE
WERE TOLD THAT IF THIS IS THE
WORK DESIGNERS WANT TO DO THAT
THEY SHOULD GO BACK TO SCHOOL TO
BECOME ARCHITECTS. AGAIN WITH A-
PREDOMINATELY- WOMEN LED
INDUSTRY THAT'S NOT SPAM VERY
PREJUDICIAL STATEMENT. CCAC WILL
HOWEVER CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN AN EFFORT TO
IMPROVE THE BENEFIT AND BENEFIT
CALIFORNIA'S INTERIOR DESIGN
PROFESSION AS A WHOLE. ISSUE
NUMBER THREE THE COMMERCIAL
DESIGNATION. HE AGAIN C. IDEAS
ARE AT THE MERCY OF INDIVIDUAL
BUILDING OFFICIALS AND THEIR
POLICIES REGARDING FAN CHECK
ACCEPTANCE AND PERMIT PERMIT
ISSUANCE EVERY BUILDING
DEPARTMENT IS DIFFERENT AND IS
BUILDING OFFICIALS COME AND GO
OUR POLICIES MAY CHANGE THE ONLY
WAY TO CHANGE THIS IS TO
STRENGTHEN THIS CURRENCY ID LAW
BY ADDING PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED
LANGUAGE ALLOWING C. IDEAS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH THE
COMMERCIAL DESIGNATION THE
ABILITY TO DO HORIZONTAL EXITING
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE CBC. THE
A. I. A. AND PERHAPS OTHERS WILL
PUSH BACK ON THIS RECOMMENDATION
EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE MANY
BUILDING DEPARTMENTS AND
OFFICIALS THAT ALLOWED THIS. I
THINK YOU HAVE ONE MORE THAT IS
THE- YES CONTRACT ISSUE ISSUE
NUMBER THE CONTRACT YES. I'M. WE
CAN WE CAN SERVE YOU WE CAN
SIMPLY ASK QUESTIONS IF THAT.
WOULD MAKE IT EASIER. M. A. THE
ONLY CONTRACT ISSUE CCCC IDC IS
THE ONLY AIRPORT IN THE COUNTRY
THAT IS SPECIFIC CONTACT
INFORMATION AND CONTRACT
REQUIREMENTS WRITTEN INTO A
STATUTE FOR INTERIOR DESIGNERS
OTHER STATES MAY REQUIRE
CONTRACT BUT THEY DON'T SAY WHAT
KIND. AND WHAT PROTECTIONS
SHOULD BE IN IT FOR THE CONSUMER
MANSI IDEAS HAVE CONVOLUTED OR
NO CONTRACT AT ALL- SO TRYING TO
PROTECT THE DESIGNER AND NOT THE
CLIENT OR THE CONSUMER SO WE DO
HAVE IT IN OUR STATUTE. IF A
DESIGNER C. IDE- WERE FOUND NOT
TO BE USING A CONTRACT AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
BROUGHT UP WHERE- WITH THE BOARD
AS A VIOLATION OF THE CODE OF
ETHICS AND THEY COULD LOSE THEIR
CERTIFICATION. OKAY OKAY-
MEMBERS SHARE BERMAN YOU'VE BEEN
WAITING PATIENTLY THANK YOU
CHAIR OFTEN AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE PRESENTATIONS THIS
MIGHT HAVE BEEN COVERED I MIGHT
HAVE I MIGHT HAVE MISSED IT I
KNOW THIS IS YEAH I KNOW THIS
ISSUE IS TALKED ABOUT BUT- IN
SPECIFIC. ABOUT THE- C. ID STAMP
IN PLANES BEING REJECTED BY
BUILDING OFFICIALS. DO WE HAVE
ANY DATA ON HOW OFTEN THAT'S
HAPPENED AND WHAT REMEDIES IF
ANY ARE AVAILABLE TO CERTIFIED
INTERIOR DESIGNERS WHEN THAT
DOES HAPPEN. WE DON'T HAVE
ACTUAL DATA BECAUSE IT'S NOT
REPORTED TO US EVERY TIME THAT
HAPPENS- BUT WHAT GENERALLY WILL
HAPPEN IF THE C. I. D. IS Q. M.
YOU HAVE THEIR PLANS PUSH BACK
AND HAVE TO HIRE AN ARCHITECT.
THIS MEANS THAT THE ARCHITECT
HAS TO REDO THE WORK ALTOGETHER
BECAUSE A AN ARCHITECT CANNOT
STAMP ANOTHER PERSON'S DRAWINGS
A COTTON CANDY. CAUSING
CONSIDERABLE COST AND TIME DELAY
FOR THE- PROJECT. AND ARE ANY
REMEDIES AVAILABLE TO IT TO SORT
OF FIND YOUR DESIRES WHEN THIS
DOES HAPPEN OR OR DO THEY JUST
HAVE TO KIND OF ACCEPT THE
BUILDING OFFICIALS- DECISION
AND- ACT ACCORDINGLY. THANK THEY
HAVE TO ACCEPT THE DECISION WHAT
GENERALLY WILL HAPPEN IS- I'M
CERTIFIED INTERIOR DESIGNERS
WILL CALL OUR OFFICE IF THEY
HAVE A PLAN CHECK DENIAL. I'M WE
HAVE A GREAT WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH A LOT OF THE
BUILDING OFFICIALS AND WE CAN
CONTACT AND HAVE A CONVERSATION.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN IT IS NEW
PLAN CHECKING STAFF THAT HAVE
NOT YET BEEN EDUCATED- CCAC
WORKS HARD TO WORK WITH. THE
COMBO AND THE LOCAL ICC CHAPTERS
TO EDUCATE BUILDING OFFICIALS
BUT- UNTIL THEY ALL ARE IT'S ALL
THIS IS CLEAR THE LANGUAGE GETS
CLARIFIED THIS WILL BE AN
ONGOING ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU A GERMAN. LET ME
JUST ASK A COUPLE BEFORE I TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES- THE
BAGLEY KEENE OPEN MEETINGS ACT
REQUIREMENTS I'M NOT EXACTLY
SURE FROM THE TESTIMONY TODAY
WHAT EXACTLY. IT IS THE- COUNCIL
DOES TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH
BAGLEY KEENE SO. I'M NOT GOING
TO BELABOR IT HERE BUT WHAT I'D
LIKE TO SEE IS A WRITTEN
SUBMISSION TO. US THE STAFF OF
BOTH COMMITTEES AS TO YOUR
EFFORTS TO COMPLY WHICH IS. OF
COURSE TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
PUBLICLY NOTICED MEETINGS AT
LEAST TEN DAYS PRIOR TO THE
MEETING. POSTED JAN DOES IN A
WHOLE VARIETY OF OTHER
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY LISTED THE DO APPLY
. SO IF YOU COULD THE REPAIR
THAT SUBMISSION OF THE DOES YOU
KNOW THE BACKGROUND PAPER- SITES
TO THE FACT THAT YOU WERE
CURRENT BYLAWS APPARENTLY
CURRENT BYLAWS- DO NOT SEEM TO
TRACK WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF
BAGLEY KEENE SO. YEAH I'M SURE
YOU PROBABLY DO BUT IT'S NOT
CLEAR TO ME AND IT MAY NOT BE
CLEAR TO MY COLLEAGUES ON ON THE
COMMITTEES AND WE'D LIKE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT HAPPENS BEFORE WE
MOVE. FORWARD WITH SUNSET. ON
THE ISSUE OF CONTRACTS- I
HAVEN'T SPECIFICALLY PULLED THE
- BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
SECTION THAT'S REFERENCED IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER TO CHECK BUT IT
BESIDES THE FACT THAT A WRITTEN
CONTRACT IS REQUIRED SO WHAT IS
IT WHAT IS IT EXACTLY THAT THE
COUNCIL DOES TO ENSURE THAT-
INDIVIDUALS SUBJECT TO- THE
COUNCIL. DO ENTER INTO WRITTEN
CONTRACTS WITH CLIENTS.
CERTAINLY THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WHEN THEY SIGN THEIR APPLICATION
FORM THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THEY'RE SHOWN IS REQUIRED THERE
GIVEN THE- GUIDELINES OF WHAT
THEIR CONTRACTS ARE. THE ISSUE
COMES WHEN THERE ARE CERTIFIED
INTERIOR DESIGNERS THAT WORK FOR
LARGE CORPORATIONS- THOSE
CORPORATIONS WILL BE THE ONES
DOING THE CONTRACTS NOT THE
CERTIFIED INTERIOR DESIGNERS AND
A LARGE POPULATION OF OUR SURVEY
INTERIOR DESIGNERS WORK FOR
THESE CORPORATIONS- BUT WE DO.
MONITOR THIS BASED ON COMPLAINTS
IF THERE ARE COMPLAINTS THAN
THEIR PART BEFORE THE BOARDING
COULD LOSE THEIR CERTIFICATION
BUT WE HAD NO SUCH COMPLAINTS-
REGARDING CONTRACTS SO OTHER
THAN US EDUCATING THEM GIVING
THEM THE INFORMATION THEM
SIGNING THAT THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT UNTIL A COMPLAINT IS
RECEIVED. THERE'S NO FURTHER WAY
THAT WE CAN- ENFORCE IT. WELL
THANK YOU THAT THAT ANSWER THE
QUESTION YOU. ADDRESS THE ISSUE
HAVING TO DO WITH THE EIGHTY
THREE COMPLAINTS REFERENCED IN
THE BACKGROUND REPORT AND I
APPRECIATED MEMBERS. ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS I
SEE. NO MICROPHONES UP SO LET'S
MOVE TO. TESTIMONY FROM MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR INTERIOR
DESIGN CERTIFICATION FIRST-
THAT'S BEING BEGIN WITH
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY WE HAVE
A WITNESS IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MEMBERS- MY
NAME IS LAURA TAYLOR I'M A
COMMERCIAL INTERIOR DESIGNER AND
I REPRESENT. IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
INTERIOR DESIGN INTERNATIONAL
INTERIOR DESIGN ASSOCIATION OR
THE I. IDA- SPECIFICALLY I WANT
TO COMMENT ON THE COMMERCIAL
DESIGNATION WHICH WAS MENTIONED
SO. I WANT TO SUPPORT THE
DESIGNATION OF A COMMERCIAL
INTERIOR DESIGNER IT WAS
MENTIONED THAT THERE IS NO
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A RESIDENTIAL
AND COMMERCIAL. INTERIOR
DESIGNER BUT THEN WHY DOES IT
NEED THE DIFFERENCE- AS A
COMMERCIAL INJURED IS THERE IT
IS A DISTINCT SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
WE PRACTICE IN THE CODE IMPACTED
ENVIRONMENT SO. WE WORK ON
PROJECTS LIKE AIRPORTS HOSPITALS
WORK SPACES- RESTAURANTS ALL OF
THOSE THINGS THAT DIVERSE ARRAY
OF PROJECTS- AND WE WORK
ALONGSIDE PEER PROFESSIONAL SO
ARCHITECTS ENGINEERS. LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECTS- WHO ALL HAVE STAMPS.
THEY GIVE THEM EXPANDED
PRACTICES- AND AS IT WAS
MENTIONED WE HAVE AN ISSUE WITH
OUR STAMP ACCEPTANCE BUT WE ALSO
DON'T FOLLOW THE SAME.
CERTIFICATION STRUCTURE THAT
THOSE. PROFESSIONALS DO- SO
THOSE BEER PROFESSIONAL SIT FOR
THE NATIONAL STANDARD EXAM. AND
THEN THEY SAID FOR A CALIFORNIA
SUPPLEMENTAL EXAM. AND THEN THEY
RECEIVE STATE CERTIFICATION WITH
THOSE EXPANDED PRIVILEGES- SO
THE MCAD Q. WHICH WAS MENTIONED.
THE NATIONAL STANDARD EXAM FOR
COMMERCIAL INTERIOR DESIGN
COMPETENCE AND THAT EXAM IS NOT
REQUIRED FOR A C. ID. OR FOR THE
COMMERCIAL DESIGNATION- SO FOR
US WHAT THAT MORE TYPICAL
STRUCTURE REPAIR PROFESSIONALS
MIGHT LOOK LIKE. WOULD BE
SITTING HERE AFTER EDUCATION
SITTING FOR THIS NATIONAL
STANDARD EXAM. SITTING FOR A
CALIFORNIA SUPPLEMENTAL EXAM
WHICH COULD BE EXISTING IDEX
EXAM IT COVERS IMPORTANT TOPICS
CALIFORNIA CODE SAFETY ISSUES
THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO OUR STATE
VERY IMPORTANT. AND THEN
RECEIVING A STATE CERTIFICATION
THAT GIVES US THOSE EXPANDED
PRACTICE PRIVILEGES- I DON'T
THINK THAT WE WANT TO MAKE A
COMMENT ON ANYTHING. IN THE C.
EIGHT THAT WORKS WELL FOR.
RESIDENTIAL DESIGNERS ARE OTHER
DESIGNERS IF THE CERTIFICATION
WORKS FOR THEN THAT'S FANTASTIC-
I WANT TO RECOMMEND TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO TAKE SOME TIME. TO REVIEW
THIS ERTIFICATION- AND MAKE
SOME MEANINGFUL PROGRESS ON THE
ISSUES OF STAMP ACCEPT
ACCEPTANCE AND- TESTING. THAT
HAVE COME UP SEVERAL SUNSET
REVIEWS IN A ROW- AND I WANT TO
OFFER THE ENTIRE DESIGN
ASSOCIATION MYSELF. AS A
RESOURCE FOR QUESTIONS AND
CONTEXT. AND I DON'T YOU KNOW
I'D LIKE TO ASK THAT WE NOT
EXTEND FOR ANOTHER FOUR YEARS.
THE CERTIFICATION THAT IS
CLEARLY NOT WORKING FOR SOME
COMMERCIAL INTERIORS THERE'S
LIKE MYSELF. AND INSTEAD MAKE
SOME SOME MEANINGFUL PROGRESS TO
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
COME AND TO PROVIDE YOUR COMMENT
AND WE WILL- WE WILL ATTEMPT TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. ANY FURTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE GALLERY I
SEE SOMEONE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE SIR PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD AND
PROCEED- HI FOLKS HOW'S IT
GOING- MY NAME IS ADAM NEWTON
AND WITH MY COLLEAGUE LAURA. I
AM ALSO HERE SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF IDA NORTHERN CALIFORNIA- I
WORK AS A PROJECT MANAGER FOR
SUTTER HEALTH I'M ACTUALLY
ACTUALLY HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE- MY TERRITORY IS
CEMENTED SETTERS BUILDINGS AND
CAPITAL PROJECTS AND-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. BERMAN'S
DISTRICT I HE'S DOWN THERE NINE
- I AM TRAINED AND EDUCATED AS
AN ARCHITECT BUT CHOSE TO
PRACTICE. IN A COMMERCIAL
INTERIOR DESIGN SCOPE
SPECIFICALLY DOING HEALTHCARE
INTERIORS ADDS A LITTLE BRAGGING
ABOUT I LIKE TO SAY IF YOU'VE
BEEN IN A HOSPITAL IN THE BAY
AREA YOU'VE LIKELY. BEEN IN ONE
OF MY PROJECTS OR AT LEAST USE
ONE OF THEM. THE PLACEMENT WALLS
AND CEILINGS- SPECIFICATION OF
FIRE RESISTANT FABRICS. THE
DESIGN OF YOUR LOCAL HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY OR DELIVERY ROOMS-
EVEN YOUR KID'S CLASSROOM. ARE
ALL THINGS AND ENDURES HONORS
QUALIFIED TO DO. AND THIS WORK
THE WORK THAT WE DO HAS HELPED
ELEVATE CALIFORNIA'S INTERIOR
SPACES TO LEAD IN THE COUNTRY
AND SUSTAINABILITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY. AND FIRE AND LIFE
SAFETY. DESPITE THIS THOUGH IF
YOUR DESIGN IS THE ONLY DESIGN
PROFESSION IN THE STATE WITHOUT
A NATIONAL STANDARD EXAM. AND A
REGULATING STATE AGENCY. THAT'S
SOMEONE WHOSE PRACTICE IN
ARCHITECTURE AND DESIGN AND NOW
AS AN OWNER'S RAP I CAN TELL YOU
IT HERE IS THAT DESIGNERS HAVE A
UNIQUE EXPERTISE TO CREATE
FUNCTIONAL AND MEANINGFUL SPACES
. WHAT I WORK ON AFFORDABLE AND
HOMELESS HOUSING PROJECTS IT WAS
MY INTERIOR DESIGN EXPERTISE
THAT LED ME TO PROPOSE
ADDITIONAL INSULATION FOR WALLS
TO HELP- VETERANS WHO WITH GOOD
EXPERIENCE AUDITORY TRIGGERS.
FOR LOUD URBAN ENVIRONMENTS. IT
WAS ALSO MY EXPERTISE- THAT
HEALTH PLAN A PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCY UNIT WITH BUILT IN
FLOORING INDICATORS TO INDICATE
SAFETY THRESHOLDS FOR STAFF WHEN
DEALING WITH COMPLICATED
PATIENTS. AS YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD TODAY- THIS PROFESSION IS
LED BY WOMEN MEMBERS OF THE
BUYBACK UNITY AND I'LL SPEAK TO
KEEP PEOPLE. THE LACK OF
STANDARDIZED PRIVILEGES THAT
ALIGN WITH OUR PEER DESIGN
PROFESSIONALS LIKE ARCHITECTS OR
CIVIL ENGINEERS. MAKES IT JUST
THAT MUCH HARDER TO COMPETE
ECONOMICALLY AND PROFESSIONALLY.
AS A MEMBER OF THE QUEER
COMMUNITY MYSELF I STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT THE LACK OF
STANDARDIZED CODE FIVE
PRIVILEGES FACING OUR PROFESSION
IS OF INCREDIBLE IMPORTANCE TO
CORRECT. AND IF THERE'S ONE BIG
THING I WANT YOU TO ALL OF YOU
KNOW TAKE AWAY FROM THIS- IT'S A
COMMERCIAL INTERIORS THE
DESIGNERS WANT PROPER LEGAL
REGULATION. AND PRIVILEGES FOR
THE WORK THAT WE ARE QUALIFIED
TO DO IT AND ACTUALLY ARE
ALREADY DOING. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THE COMMITTEE TO LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE LAURA SAID IT TAKE A
PROGRESSIVE STEP AND GRANT AN
EXTENSION OF TIME FOR THIS
PROFESSION TO BE. THOROUGHLY
EXAMINED INSTEAD OF JUST KICKING
THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD ANOTHER
FOUR YEARS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOUSIR FOR YOUR TIME AND
YOUR COMMENTS. ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY. SEEING
NO OTHER WITNESSES- LET'S MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT- THROUGH THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE.
THE MONEY ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
COUNCIL WE SHOW. PROCEED THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN THE GENTLEMAN TO
PROVIDE COMMENT PRESS ONE ZERO
TO BE PROVIDED WITH A LINE
NUMBER YOU MY NUMBER IS CALLED
ST UNIFICATION TO LEGISLATIVE
RECORD WE GO NOT A LINE NUMBER
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SIX
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MARK CHRISTIAN
WITH THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS CALIFORNIA. A. I.
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS EXTENDING
THE SUNSET DATE FOR US HE ID TWO
YEARS BECAUSE SHE C. IDC DOES
PROVIDE A BENEFIT TO CONSUMERS.
INTERIOR DESIGNERS AND ANYONE
ELSE WITH ANY OTHER UNLICENSED
PERSON CAN PROVIDE DESIGN
SERVICES. UNDER AN EXEMPTION IN
THE ARCHITECTS PRACTICE ACT THAT
EXEMPTION ALLOWS ANYONE TO
PROVIDE CLIENT SERVICES FOR NON
STRUCTURAL AND NON SEISMIC WORK
IN WORK THAT DOES NOT AFFECT THE
SAFETY OF THE BUILDING. WORK
THAT DOES INVOLVE THE DESIGN OF
STRUCTURAL OR SEISMIC WORK WITH
THAT DOES AFFECT THE SAFETY OF
THE BUILDING IT HAS TO BE
PREPARED BY AN ARCHITECT AND
ENGINEER. THIS IS LONG
ESTABLISHED LAW. SO FOR THE
EXEMPTION. P. C. ID SEE-
PROVIDES A BENEFIT TO CONSUMERS-
CONSUMER DOES THAT SOMEONE WHO
IS A CERTIFIED INTERIOR DESIGNER
IS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS
DEMONSTRATED COMPETENCE THROUGH
THE THREE E. EDUCATION
EXPERIENCE AND EXAMINATION
THAT'S THE VALUE TO THE CONSUMER
AND WHY WE SUPPORT EXTENDING THE
SUNSET DATE ON THE LAW TO ALLOW
CCA QC TO CERTIFY ENTER SIGNERS.
ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT- SOME.
INFORMATION ALONG HOPEFULLY
YOU'LL- FIND OUT PLEASE. ABOUT
PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS AND
ARCHITECTURAL SCHOOLS TODAY IN
THE UNITED STATES ARE WOMEN MORE
WOMEN ARE ENTERED INTO THE
PROFESSION OF ARCHITECTURE AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE DAY WHERE
THERE IS COMPLETE PARITY IN THE
PRACTICE OF ARCHITECTURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SIR.
MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE. NEXT JULY
THIRTEENTH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHAIRMAN ROSTENKOWSKI CHAIRMAN
BERMAN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
MATTHEW BRUCHE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR THE COUNCIL
FOR INTERIOR DESIGN
QUALIFICATION. INTO THE WRITTEN
COMMENTS SUBMITTED BY OUR CEO
TOM BANKS IN SUPPORT OF THE
INTERNATIONAL INTERIOR DESIGN
ASSOCIATION REQUEST FOR
COLLABORATION. I WOULD LIKE TO
SUBMIT THE FOLLOWING CLARIFYING
COMMENTS AS THERE HAS BEEN A
GREAT DEAL MENTION OF THE M. J.
Q. IN THE BACKGROUND PAPER AND
IN STATE TAX MONEY. SO I WOULD
LIKE TO PRIDE COMMITTEE BACKS.
THE NCAA QUEUED THEM IF THE
NATIONAL STANDARD FOR
COMPARTMENT YES THAT'S AN
INTERIOR DESIGN. THE MCAD Q.
EXAMINES THE PREREQUISITE FOR
CERTIFYING THE CARRIAGES ON
REGULAR REGISTRATION OR
LICENSURE IN THIRTY U. S.
JURISDICTIONS. AND ALL CANADIAN
PROVINCES. STATE LEGISLATORS
RECOGNIZED THE M. K. Q. AND
CONTINUE TO DO SO AND UTILIZING
DAMMIT THE BASIS FOR REASONABLE
REGULATION. EXEMPLIFIED BY THE
PASSAGE OF NORTH CAROLINA'S
TITLE ACT LAST YEAR AND BY
LEGISLATION IS STATUS THE
PERMITTING FROM WHICH THE
JOURNALING MOVING IN WISCONSIN
ILLINOIS AND IOWA. LANGUAGE
WHICH HAS ALL BEEN AGREED UPON
WITH EACH DAY COMPONENT OF THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS. AND CREATE THE EXACT
KIND OF CLARIFYING LANGUAGE THAT
MISLEADS SPOKE UP IN THAT
BUILDING OFFICIALS ARE
REQUESTING. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS UNIQUE NEEDS IN
REGULATING THE DESIGN
PROFESSIONS DO IT STATES IT'S
DIFFICULT BECAUSE THE STANDARDS
. THAT IS THE MOST FREQUENTLY
CITED REASON AGAINST UTILIZATION
OF A NATIONAL INTERIORS ARE
CONFIDENT. AND IS THIS STAGE
PRIVATE TO DECIDE HOW TO ADDRESS
THOSE NEEDS. THAT IS HOW THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAME TO
REQUIRE CALIFORNIA SUPPLEMENTAL
EXAMINATION. IN ADDITION TO
NATIONAL COMPETITION IS ABSENT
THOSE REQUIREMENTS FOR LICENSURE
IN SEVERAL OTHER REGULATED
PROFESSIONS. THIS MODEL APPEARS
TO HAVE WORKED FOR CALIFORNIA
AND ALLOWING ITS WORKERS TO
ENJOY THE BENEFITS AND RIGOR OF
KNOWN CERTIFICATION VOLUNTEERING
THAT SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC IS-CONTINUE TO BE PROTECTED AND THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF THE STATE. OUR
MAPS. THEY THEY'RE THINKING
GROWED AND HOW THE STATE
REGULATES THE DESIGN PROFESSION
. THE MODEL OF A NATIONAL
COMPETENCY ASSESSMENT WITH
EDUCATION AND EXPERIENCE
REQUIREMENTS UTILIZING
CONJUNCTION WITH CFT IS IT HOW
CALIFORNIA REGULATES ALL OTHER
DESIGN PROFESSIONS INCLUDING
ARCHITECTURE. WHICH HAS TO STING
SIMILARITIES WITH INTERIOR
DESIGN. ONLY INTERIOR DESIGN
DOES NOT HAVE THIS MODEL. IT HAS
BEEN WELL DOCUMENTED THERE ARE
MANY AREAS OF CORRELATION
BETWEEN THE PRESENCE OF
ARCHITECTURE DESIGN INCLUDING
REQUIRED AREAS OF COMPETENCY AND
PROFESSIONAL KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILLS THAT ARE SIMILAR AND
SUBSTANTIALLY I AND SOME CASES
SOME STRANGELY IDENTICAL. RECENT
RESEARCH CONDUCTED BY CID QUEUE
AND THE NATIONAL COUNCIL OF
ARCHITECTURAL REGISTRATION
BOARDS. SHOWED SIGNIFICANT
SIMILARITIES BETWEEN OUR
RESPECTIVE PRACTICE NOW PLEAD
AND EXAM. A GROUP OF SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS FROM BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS FOUND THAT EIGHTY
THREE POINT 3% OF THE OBJECTIVES
KNOWLEDGE AREAS OF THE MCAT
QUEUE WITH THEM. HAD DEFINITE-
SOME SIMILARITY TO OUR
OBJECTIVES AND OUR KNOWLEDGE
AREAS OF AND CARS ARCHITECT
REGISTRATION EXAM. THAT IS NOT
TO SAY THE TWO EXAMS ARE THE
SAME THEY ARE NOT. THE ENTIRE
QUEUE IS THE NATIONAL
CERTIFICATION FOR INTERIOR
DESIGN. JUST AS THE A. R. E. IF
THE NATIONAL LICENSURE
EXAMINATION FOR OUR TAX. THEY
BOTH SUFFICIENTLY AND ADEQUATELY
ADAPT COMPETENCY IN THE SCOPES
OF PRACTICE ON EACH PROFESSION.
WHICH WHILE THE STATE DOES CARRY
MANY SIMILARITIES. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOES CURRENTLY
UTILIZE THE AIRY BUT NOT THE
MCAD Q. SIR. AND FINALLY I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SAY THAT WE HAVE
ALL THE SAME CARD GO AHEAD AND
GO WITH THIS ISSUE THE PUBLIC
PROTECTION HOW SAFETY WELFARE.
IN THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT. I WILL
CONCLUDE JUST BY SAYING THAT
THESE FACTS FOR OUT A SIMPLE
REALITY WE AGREE. WITH EARLIER
TESTIMONY THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD CRITICALLY RE
EXAMINE THE CERTIFIED INTERIOR
DESIGNER STYLE ACT. AND HOW TO
REGULATE THE PROFESSION OF
INTERIOR DESIGN. NOT DOING SO
THE DISSERVICE TO PREDOMINATELY
FEMALE FASHION. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT REVISITED THE
FRAMEWORKS AND THE PASSAGE OF
THE INITIAL ARM IN NINETEEN
NINETY. AREA DEVELOPMENT OF NOT
ONLY THE INTERIOR DESIGN
PROFESSION BUT REGULATION AS
WELL HAVE TAKEN PLACE DURING
THAT TIME. U. DEVELOPMENTS
INCLUDE SEVERAL STATES HAVE
PASSED LEGISLATION GRANTING AND
HEARING CERTIFIED HERE DESIGNER
STEPHAN CEILING PRIVILEGES
ESTABLISHING JOINT OR- IN SOME
CASES- PROVIDING PERMANENT
VILLAGES ALL IN THE PAST AND
BASED ON THE PASSAGE OF THE
UNDEAD GIVE. SIR NOT ONLY IS
THIS CURRENT HELLO YEAH. YOU
HAVE NOW MOVED NEAR ME YES I CAN
VERY WELL AND YOU'RE NOW MOVING
TO FIVE MINUTES WHICH IS. ALMOST
THREE TIMES. WELL LET ME JUST
SAY THIS. I'M NOT NORMALLY THE
DETAIL THAT YOU PROVIDED IS NOT
THE KIND OF DETAIL WE TAKEN
PUBLIC COMMENT BUT I'M DELIGHTED
TO DO SO. BUT IF YOU WANT YOUR
BROTHER DETAILED COMMENTS- THAT
APPEAR TO HAVE BEEN REDUCED TO
WRITING CONSIDERED BY THE
COMMITTEES THAT ARE CONDUCTING
THIS JOINT HEARING. I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT YOU SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS THE WRITTEN ONES THAT
YOU HAVE. TO COMMITTEE STAFF SO
THAT THEY CAN BE FULLY
CONSIDERED AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THIS JOINT- SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS ON THIS PARTICULAR
COUNCIL SO. THIRTY SECONDS
CONCLUDING STATEMENT. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR WE HAVE INDEED DONE SO
AND TO BE CLEAR NOBODY IS
SUGGESTING THAT THE STEADY C.
SHOULD HAVE NO ROLE IN
REGULATING CARE DESIGN WE ARE
NOT SUGGESTING THAT YOU DO AWAY
WITH THE I. DAX THE OBVIOUS
SOLUTION TO DEATH WHEN THEY
ALREADY HAVE SUBMITTED BY THE
STATE AND COULD BE UTILIZED
FRONTIER DESIGN. SHE HAD ACUTE
HAPPY TO BE A RESOURCE FOR THE
WEBSITE FROM THE DISHES AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR
COMMENTS MR MODERATOR NEXT.
THANK YOU ALIGN NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING EVERYBODY MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE PETER I READ THAT
REPRESENT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I.
IDA AS THE COMMERCIAL INTERIOR
DESIGNER AND A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER ALSO AT THE OWNER'S RAP. I
HAD TO ACCEPT FULL ON I DID WELL
IN UTILIZING MY DESIGNER PLANTS
FOR COMMERCIAL PROJECTS. BUT I
DO HAVE. WHO REGULARLY HAVE
THEIR PLANS REJECTED SIMPLY
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT FORMALLY
DESIGNATED AS DESIGN
PROFESSIONALS WITH STAMPS
ACCORDING TO ONE OF MY COLLEAGUE
ACTUALLY HAD TO HIRE AN
ARCHITECT TIME TO OUR STAFF. AND
LEFT AN EXPERIENCE THEN SHE DID
BUT IT DID ALLOW HER TO HAVE A
DIVINE GROWING AND IT IS AN
APPROVED EASIER. ITS PRODUCT-
ADDED COST IN TRYING TO DESIGN
PROJECT AND OPEN TO THE END USER
PROJECT AS WELL. IT MAKES NO
SENSE. I KNOW AT ANYTIME MY LUCK
COULD CHANGE AND I WILL BE PUT
IN THE SAME SITUATION. WHILE I
APPRECIATE THE IDEA THE
ACCOUNTING THAT THE COMMERCIAL
INTERIOR DESIGN CERTIFICATIONS
AT THE PLATE AND CURRENTLY HAVE
ISSUES. DAVID TO DEFINE A PATH
FOR COMMERCIAL INJURED YOU
BUYING IT UNFORTUNATELY IT IS
NOT EFFECTIVE AND HE DID NOT
SOLVE THE PROBLEM. THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY FACING. R. ASK IT FOR
SURE BECAUSE THE OF THE YEAR
PRIOR TO ANOTHER YOU'RE APPROVED
. WE'D LIKE TO ALLOW TO RESOLVE
THE UNCALLED ISSUE ATTEMPT
ACCEPTANCE AND COMMERCIAL
DESIGNATION AND WE AT IDA WOULD
LIKE TO COME TO THE TABLE AND
HELP THEM WITH THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND STAKEHOLDERS. THANK
YOU THANK. YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT GO TO ONE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH. MY
NAME IS LINDA PANETTONE I MENTOR
AND DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE. SIGN I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS OF BEING
SIGNED OVER THIRTY YEAR. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE. YOUR POINT.
THE IDC OKAY HAS ALWAYS BEEN ON
AS LONG AS IT'S BEEN IN
EXISTENCE FOR ANY HEALTH SAFETY
. AND INCLUDING. THAT
DEVELOPMENT OF A STRONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE BUILDING
DEPARTMENT. AND I WOULD HIGHLY-
EXCEPT THAT THE CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
ALL DESIGNERS TO PRACTICE. B. C.
ID HE IS NOT GENERIC LIKE B. AND
C. I. D. Q. EIGHT PM. THE N. P.
I. D. Q. EXAM CONTINUED TO BE
PROMOTED BY I. D. A. N. A. S. I.
S. THE ONLY EXAM THEY CAN'T
ACCOMPLISH. OF A RESIDENTIAL OR
COMMERCIAL DESIGNER. BUT THE
ANTI ID Q. DID NOT CARE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE CALGARY.
TITLE TWENTY FOUR. THE IDC EXAM
YEAH I DON'T THINK DOES GET BACK
. NUMBER THREE. CIBC INITIATED A
COMMERCIAL DESIGNATION THIS
TECHNICIAN UNLIKE WORKED OUT
WITH THEM. HELLO AND-
INTERNATIONAL CODE COUNCIL AND
ITS DESIGNATION REQUIRED MORE
EDUCATION YOU CAN HEAR
COMMERCIAL DESIGN DESIGNER IS
NOW REQUIRED TO CATCH AT LEAST
FIVE ADDITIONAL COURT
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNATED BY THE
INTERNATIONAL CRICKET COUNCIL IN
ORDER TO GET BACK. TO A
COMMERCIAL DESIGNATION. NO NEED
FOR FURTHER REVIEW FOR A AND THE
H. AND R. EIGHT. EXCUSE ME I
CAN'T COPE THAT ALREADY PROVIDE
EVERYTHING NEEDED GRAIN JURY TO
FIND. MY DEGREE IN AND
CERTIFICATION IN BOTH COMMERCIAL
AND RESIDENTIAL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU PLEASE
SUPPORT US SUBMIT YOUR- IF YOU
HAVE THEM IN READING YOUR
COMMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE'S
STAFF MEMBERS. FOR CONSIDERATION
MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE. ACTUALLY
TWENTY FIVE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS NICOLE JULIAN GRANT I AM
I AM EIGHTY EIGHT THAT IN
CALIFORNIA V. P. OF ADVOCACY AND
A JOB CAPTAIN AND SENIOR
ASSOCIATE H. O. W. ONE OF THE
OLDEST ARCHITECTURAL FIRMS IN
THE UNITED STATES. I HAVE TWENTY
YEARS OF CONSTRUCTION EXPERIENCE
IN MY PRIMARY PROFESSIONAL ROLE
. CITING DOCUMENTS TO PLAN CHECK
THE WORLD THAT WE ARE SPEAKING
UP. MARSHALL HERE DESIGNERS
ESPECIALLY NEW PROFESSIONAL ARE
CONFUSED BY THE CERTIFICATION
STRUCTURE BECAUSE IT'S STILL
WIDELY DIFFERENT FROM MARKET
PROFESSIONAL LIKE ARCHITECT
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECT AND
ENGINEER. WHO TAKE A NATIONALLY
BASED EXAM AND A CALIFORNIA
COUPLE MENTAL EXAM TO BECOME
REGISTERED THROUGH THE DPA.
HOWEVER IN DESIGN CERTIFICATION
REGISTRATION ANOTHER THANK YOU
TO LIKE THE NATIONAL EXAM AT THE
BASE OF THE GAP AND ALSO REQUIRE
SUPPLEMENTS WITH NOT FOR
CALIFORNIA. CONTRACTING AT THE
THEM THEIR GRANTED A STAMPING
AND PRIVILEGE TO TAKE THE
PROJECT APARTMENT. P. FIFTY
CAN'T CANISTER DO BETTER PRINT
YOUR DIVINERS. WE ARE NOT
GRANTED CAMPAIGN FEEL PRIVILEGES
UNDER MOST JURISDICTIONS IN FACT
I PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED. ISSUE
WHEN I CLICK IN PLANT CITY THEY
EXPECT ME TO HAVE A MALE
COLLEAGUE COME WITH ME
TRANSACTION IN SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE TECHNICAL FIELD THAT I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON FOR TWENTY
YEARS. YEAH I DO LOOK VERY WELL
FOR SOME INTERIOR DESIGNERS AND
DECORATORS. AND YOU SHOULD HAVE
A PROPER DISCUSSION TO CONSIDER
THOSE PROFESSIONAL. THE DESIGN
COMMERCIAL PAPER THE NATIONAL
CALIFORNIA LIKE THE BILLION
OVERSIGHT IS APPROPRIATE AND
REFLECT THE CURRENT PROFESSION.
W THANK THE COMMITTEE AND YOUR
STAFF IDENTIFYING THE TWO
CURRENT ISSUE THE STAFF FEEL
LIKE TALKING YOU CAN ISSUE AND
COMMERCIAL DESIGNATION IF THE
PROBLEM. HOWEVER THE DISHES HAVE
BEEN UNRESOLVED FOR NOW IDEA YOU
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
COMMITTED STAFF AND STAKEHOLDERS
WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS I WOULD
HOPE WITH ALL. OUR ATHLETES FOR
SHORT EXTENSION OF TIME TO DO SO
FOR ANOTHER. YEAR FOR FOOTBALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MARK NEXT.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MISS BY WRITER HAVING HEARD
PUBLIC TESTIMONY MEMBERS ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR INTERIOR
DESIGN CERTIFICATION. I SEE NO
MICROPHONES UP SO LET'S MOVE ON
TO. THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
OCCUPATIONAL THIRTY THREE SIR
YES I JUST I CAN'T FIND THE
RAISE MY HAND MAY IF I MAY.
RESPOND WHAT WILL ME JUST SEE OH
I'M SORRY I DIDN'T EVEN I
APOLOGIZE. YES ANY APOLOGIES I
THINK A COUPLE OF THINGS I AM
FIRST OFF THE COMMERCIAL
DESIGNATION W. NORMAN JEWISON
WHO MANAGES THAT WE TYPICALLY
DON'T. HAVE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR RESPONSES TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU FEEL
COMPELLED TO DO AT THIS POINT IN
TIME. YEAH THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SORRY I DIDN'T SEE YOU ON THE
SCREEN. WE WERE MOVING ON TO THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY LET'S WELCOME SURE AND
PREVENT SH BOARD PRESIDENT AND
HEATHER MARTIN EXECUTIVE OFFICER
. THANK YOU GENERAL BERMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I AM
DOCTOR SURE POPOVICH AND I HAD
THE DISTINCT PLEASURE OF SERVING
AS THE CURRENT PRESIDENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY IN THE CAPACITY IT
DOESN'T OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSISTANT. THE COMPANY ME TODAY
IS OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER HEATHER
MARTIN AND JUST A REALLY QUICK
GRATITUDE CHECK- FOR THE BOARD
STAFF AND BOARD TO YOU KNOW MAKE
GREAT PAINTER PUTTING THE SUNSET
REVIEW TOGETHER SO JUST TO BE
PART OF HISTORY ABOUT
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY. THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
PROFESSIONAL WAS ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN AND IS ONE OF
THE OLDEST ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONS IN THE UNITED
STATES. SENATE BILL ONE ZERO
FOUR SIX CREATED THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY ON
JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND AND
ONE THE BOARD'S MISSION AND
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AS OF
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY SERVICES
THROUGH EFFECTIVE REGULATION AND
APPROPRIATE LICENSING OF
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY.
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST KNOWN AS
O. T. AS IN OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSISTANTS KNOWN AS O. T. A.'S
TOGETHER THEY COMPRISE WHAT WE
CALL. A CHRISTIAN THERAPY
PRACTITIONERS. WHEN THE BOARD
STARTED INTO THOU ONE YOU WAS
DESTINED THAT THERE BE UPON.
EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED NEWLY LIFE
OCCUPATIONAL PRACTITIONERS IN
CALIFORNIA. BY THE END OF THE
FISCAL YEAR 200-082-0009 THERE
WERE NEARLY THIRTEEN THOUSAND
LICENSEES AND TODAY THERE ARE
MORE THAN A LITTLE OVER NINETEEN
THOUSAND. THE VALUE OF
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY SERVICES AS
NOTED BY THE NUMBER OF NEW
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY EDUCATION
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA. IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE THERE WERE SIX
OKAY PROGRAMS AND FOR- EXCUSE ME
SIX OH DEEPER. GIVE ME. THERE
WERE- SIX OH TWO PROGRAMS AND
FOR OTA PROGRAMS THAT NUMBER IS
NOW DOUBLED. THERE ARE CURRENTLY
TEN OH TWO PROGRAMS AND ELEVEN
OTA PROGRAMS WITH SIX ADDITIONAL
SCHOOLS IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING EITHER IN O. T. R. O.
TA PROGRAM. UNDER ACCREDITATION.
TO SUPPORT CONSUMER PROTECTION
BOARD ESTABLISHED ETHICAL
STANDARDS OF PRACTICE STANDARDS
OF PRACTICE FOR TELEHEALTH.
SUPERVISION REQUIREMENTS
ADVANCED PRACTICE REQUIREMENTS
MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR INFECTION
CONTROL AND CONTINUING EDUCATION. COMPETENCY REQUIREMENTS. IN
ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH MISSION BUT
BOY. ENSURES A ELIGIBLE AND
COLOR INDIVIDUALS ARE ISSUED A
LICENSE AND INVESTIGATES
COMPLAINTS CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS
AND DISCIPLINE ORDERS ISSUED BY
OTHER STATES. THE BOARD STATUTES
REQUIRES INDIVIDUALS WITH FEW
EXCEPTIONS ENGAGING IN THE
PRACTICE OF OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
TO POSSESS A LICENSE. ANOTHER
RISK IN ORDER TO RESPOND TO THE
CODE PANDEMIC THERE WERE SEVERAL
CHANGES. THE BOARD AND COMMITTEE
MEETINGS MOTOR VIRTUAL PLATFORM
BOARD STOCK BEGAN ROTATIONAL
TELEWORK AND IN PERSON WORK
SCHEDULES. THE BOARDED BY THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
PRACTITIONERS THIS WAY FIRST
ISSUED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. WEBSITE
UPDATES AND THE USE OF SOCIAL
MEDIA AND THE BOARD TRACKED OUT
OF STATE LICENSE HE'S WORKING IN
CALIFORNIA. UNDER THE
AUTHORIZATION OF THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY.
SINCE THE LAST SUNSET REVIEW
HEARING IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BOARD AMONG OTHER THINGS HAS
PARTNERED I DON'T KNOW T. WORK
FOR WORK FOR STUDY. UPDATED THE
FUNCTIONALITY OF BREEZE. CREATED
IT'S TWENTY TWENTY STRATEGIC
PLAN AND BUILT UPON ITS STAKE
HOLDERS OUTREACH THE BOARD
CONTINUES TO WORK WITH
APPOINTING AUTHORITIES ON BOARD
APPOINTMENTS. THERE'S A
DISCUSSION FOR ANY DIFFERENT-
TEAMWORK FOR STUDY AS WELL AS
DISCUSSION REVOLVING ADVANCED
PRACTICE REQUIREMENTS RELEVANT
TO UPDATED ACCREDITATION
GUIDELINES AND CURRICULUM
CHANGES. ALSO CONSIDERATION OF
AN ATTESTATION ACKNOWLEDGING
LAWS AND REGULATIONS REGULATIONS
AND OR REQUIRING AN ETHICS
COURSE FOR INITIAL OR RENEWAL
APPLICATIONS AND LASTLY IT'S
WORKING TO ENSURE FUTURE FISCAL
SOLVENCY. WE. WELCOME ANY AND
ALL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MS
MARTIN ANY FURTHER COME. YES
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON GERMAN
ROTH VERNON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND STAFF MY NAME IS HEATHER
MARTIN IN AN EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY WHICH I'VE
HAD THE PLEASURE OF SERVING AS-
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY REPORTER
RESPONDING TO YOUR QUESTIONS AS
WELL AS THE RECOMMENDATIONS
PROVIDED IN THE PORTS
BACKGROUND. THANK YOU THANK YOU
LET'S TURN TO MEMBERS CHAIRMAN
ANY QUESTIONS. THE TEACHER OFTEN
AND THAN YOU FOR THE VERY
CONCISE PRESENTATIONS- IN TERMS
OF ISSUE NUMBER ONE- THAT THAT'S
BEEN RAISED RELATED TO THE
BOARD'S FUND CONDITION. HOW IS
THE BOARD'S REVIEW OF PROPOSED
FEE INCREASES COMING ALONG.
THANK YOU FOR THAT GERMAN BERMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT BOARD
IS TAKING PLACE- A LOOK AT THE
FUND'S CONDITION YOU'RE VERY
SERIOUSLY HISTORICALLY THE
BOARDS REVENUE AND EXPENDITURES
HAVE NOT BEEN IN ALIGNMENT
DESPITE- AND YOU WERE VERSIONS
THE REVENUE EARNED EACH YEAR-
HAS BEEN LESS THAN B.
EXPENDITURES- I BELIEVE IT WAS
NOTED AND EVEN BACK AS FAR AS
THE BOARD'S TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SENSOR REPORT- WHAT THE BOARD
DID DO WAS PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS FOR MODEST INCREASES
IN THE RENEWAL FEES AND IT WAS A
TWO STEP PROCESS. WHICH RAISE
THE FEES FOR- TINO J. RENEWALS
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
AND THEN AGAIN AND- TWENTY
TWENTY ONE UNFORTUNATELY THOSE
FEES ALONE ARE INSUFFICIENT TO
ENSURE YOU KNOW FUTURE FISCAL
SOLVENCY WITH THE- WITH THE FUND
AT RISK THE BOARD DID CAN
DISCUSS THIS AT SEVERAL
MEETINGS- LAST YEAR AND AT THE
MOST RECENT MEETING THEY TOSSED
AN AD HOC BUDGET COMMITTEE TO
REVIEW. THE- POSTED INCREASE
WHICH THERE WERE A VARIETY OF
THEM AS WELL AS YOU KNOW
EXPENDITURE REDUCTIONS TO REALLY
TAKE A LOOK AT THE ISSUE I'M
HAVING AN AD HOC COMMITTEE- WORK
ON THIS TO YOU MORE THOROUGHLY
BUT- THE ISSUE MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION AT THE BOARD- THE
BOARD'S NEXT MEETING THAT THAT
IS THE- BEST PATH FORWARD. AND
WE DO REALIZE THERE WILL BE TO
BE A FEE INCREASE NOT SURE WHAT
THAT WILL LOOK LIKE OR WHAT THAT
WILL ENTAIL AND WE LOOK BOTH FOR
TWO- COMPLETING THE COMMITTEES-
FETAL QUESTIONERS WELLS
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND- IN TERMS OF ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR RELATED TO- TI'S
OPERATING AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. HAS THE BOARD HEARD
OF ISSUES WITH- KEYS WERE UNABLE
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE CARE DUE
TO THE NEED FOR THEIR CHANGES
FOUR DO THE NEED FOR CHANGES IN
THEIR BUSINESS MODELS- WE HAVE
NOT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION SO- THERE. RIGHT NOW-
CONCERNING THE CONTRACT ISSUE
OTHER EMPLOYEE TO EMPLOYER
RELATIONSHIP ISSUE HAS NOT
REALLY BEEN DISCUSSED BY THE
BOARD- WELL THIS APPEARS TO BE
NOT SO MUCH A PRACTICE OR-
PROTECTION ISSUE. THERE ARE
MANY- TEAMS WHO ARE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AND SO- THE BOARD
LOOKS FORWARD TO DISCUSSING THE
VALUE OF THAT SECTION OF THAT TO
THE LABOR CODE FOR CONTRACTING A
TEASE AT A FUTURE BOARD MEETING.
AND KIND OF GETTING A LITTLE BIT
BETTER DESCRIPTION OF HOW THE
ALIGNMENT WITH INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS- T. BUSINESS MODELS
TO WORK. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH JIM OR QUESTION. RELATED TO
PRACTICE. ISSUE NUMBER. Q. TULSA
BIT ABOUT THE STATUS OF THE
DISCUSSION OF PHASING OUT
ADVANCED PRACTICE CERTIFICATES.
NOW THAT IT'S INCLUDED IN THE
TYPICAL- T. EDUCATION. GREAT
QUESTION THANK YOU AGAIN SO. THE
BOARD DISCUSSED SEVERAL
ITERATIONS OF THE BAND'S
PRACTICE REQUIREMENTS- WITH THAT
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ACCREDITATION
STANDARDS GOING INTO EFFECT JULY
OF TWENTY TWENTY. THE BOARD MAY
FIND IT USEFUL TO INTERVIEW THE
SCHOOLS ONCE AGAIN TO CLEAN
THEIR ASSESSMENT OF STUDENT
COMPETENCY IN THE AREAS OF. IT
EXCUSE ME BEST PRACTICE WHICH
ARE DISCLOSURE AND THEIR P. AND
PHYSICAL AGENT MODALITIES- IT
SHOULD BE NOTED THAT
ACCREDITATION STANDARD JUST FIVE
MINIMUM EDUCATION CONTENT.
HOWEVER THE STRATEGY NOT
QUANTIFY THE AMOUNT OF TIME TO
BE SPENT ON EACH TOPIC FOR
EXAMPLE SOME EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS. PRIOR HOW YOU KNOW
A LECTURE FOR THREE HOURS WHEN
I'M CERTAIN CONTENT WITH OTHER
SCHOOLS I CREATED A QUARTER OF
CLASSES BUT NOW WITH THE
ACCREDITATION STANDARDS IS THE
TIME TO REVISIT THAT FOR SURE-
REALLY THE COURSE DELIVERY IS
LEFT UP TO EACH INDIVIDUAL
SCHOOL TO DETERMINE AND
IMPLEMENT IS WHY WE PROBABLY
SHOULD. INTO THIS DISCUSSION TO
FIND OUT IF WE'RE MEETING THOSE
STANDARDS- AND IF IT'S
DETERMINED THAT EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS HAVE EQUITABLE
EDUCATION STANDARDS A DISCUSSION
CAN ENSUE WHETHER TO CONTINUE
WITH THE ADVANCED PRACTICE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS OR REMOVE THEM. FOR
FUTURE GRADUATES IF THEIR
DEMAND. IS UNIQUE THERE BEING
THAT UNIVERSALLY CONSUMER
PROTECTION- BENEFITS CAN ONLY BE
A TRIP ALL EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
MEET MINIMAL NATIONAL EDUCATION
STANDARDS I HOPE THAT ANSWERS
YOUR QUESTION. I THINK YOU DID
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE IT THANKS YOU'RE OFF.
THANK YOU RICHARD X. QUEST HELLO
WE JUST ASK A FOLLOW UP TO THE-
DYNAMIX QUESTION INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR ONE OF THE ISSUES MAY
BE WHETHER OCCUPATIONAL
ULTIMATELY MAYBE WHETHER
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS ARE
ACTUALLY ENGAGED IN AN
INDEPENDENT. BUSINESS AND I WAS
SO SORT OF FASCINATED BY THE
BACKGROUND PAPER DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE PROFESSIONAL
CORPORATION ACT AND THE APPARENT
STATUS WHICH IS THE-
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS ARE NOT
PRESENTLY AUTHORIZED TO FORM. A
PROFESSIONAL CORPORATIONS. DO
YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY EXPLANATION
AS TO REASON FOR THAT LIMITATION
AND- ONE AND TWO GIVEN THE
LIMITATION WHAT ACTION ARE WE
ENGAGED IN TO TRY TO FIX THAT
BECAUSE IT WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT
THAT WOULD BE. SOMETHING THAT AT
LEAST SOME OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS MIGHT BE INTERESTED
IN- THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN
SO. WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT IT
AS A FULL BOARD BECAUSE IT
HASN'T COME UP FOR DISCUSSION-
BUT SEEING THE DYNAMICS
OPERATIONS LESS. COURT
INFORMATION THE BACKGROUND PAPER
CERTAINLY BECAUSE- AN INTEREST
IN US TO REVISIT THIS FOR FUTURE
FOR DISCUSSION HOWEVER WHAT I
CAN SAY IS THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL BUSINESS MODELS OUT
THERE THAT SUPPORT. OTC
FUNCTIONING AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AND THEY- WE DON'T
KNOW TO WHAT EXTENT DO WE TALK
TO SUPPORT HOW THEY ALIGN OR
THEY DIFFER SO MUCH FROM- THE
I'M SORRY THE OPERATIONS FROM.
ARMS DYNAMICS SHE'S MADE UP TO
LOOK AT THAT HERE SO WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO REVISITING NOT
HOWEVER- THE INDEPENDENT WE
HAVEN'T SEEN IT COME UP AS A
CONCERN YET- EITHER PRACTICE
ISSUE OR ENFORCEMENT ISSUE- WHAT
WE REALLY NEED TO DO IS HAVE A
CONVERSATION AND SEE WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE IN TERMS OF
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY BUSINESS
MODELS. AND THE POTENTIAL OF
BEING LISTED UNDER YOUR S. WELL
OBVIOUSLY IT'S ATTRACTIVE TO
OTHERS. OTHERS IN THE HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY AND I CAN'T IMAGINE
THAT IT WOULD BE ATTRACTIVE TO
SOME OF. THE OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS THAT ARE REGULATED
BY. YOUR BOARD SO I SUGGEST YOU
DO TAKE A LOOK AT IT. BECAUSE
SEPARATE AND APART FROM YOUR
ACTIVITIES OF NFORCEMENT. AND
OTHERWISE THEY'RE PROBABLY SOME
VERY- THERE'S SOME AND- SIR TO
INCORPORATE IS AND HAVE A
PROFESSIONAL CORPORATION WHILE
THERE ARE OTHER. CERTAINLY OTHER
MODELS THAT EXIST I ASSUME- FOR
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS BEYOND
BEING A SOLE PROPRIETOR. THANK
YOU FOR TAKING A LOOK AT THAT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I WANT TO
ASK ABOUT- IN IN GOING THROUGH
THE BACKGROUND PAPER AND THE
ISSUES THAT ARE COVERED IN
THOSE- THAT WERE NOT THERE
APPEAR TO HAVE BEEN SOME ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED DURING THE LAST
SUNSET REVIEW. OF THERE WERE NOT
RESPONDED TO OR IF THEY WERE-
THEY WERE NOT RESPONDED TO- IN
DEPTH LET ME JUST SAY THAT.
QUESTIONS ABOUT UPDATES TO YOUR
APPLICATION- AND CERTIFICATIONS
BY APPLICANTS QUESTIONS OF NEAR
AND DIS FROM NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART. THE DUPLICATIVE
REQUIREMENTS AND MILITARY
APPLICANTS- A KNOWLEDGE MEANT
THAT THERE WERE DUPLICATIVE
REQUIREMENTS BUT NOT. MUCH IN
THE WAY OF COMMENT ABOUT WHAT
YOU'RE GONNA DO ABOUT IT.
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE- WELL THE
VARIOUS OTHERS WORKPLACE
WORKFORCE TRENDS DEMOGRAPHICS
DATA WHEN THE DATA WAS REQUESTED
AND ALL OF THAT SO I GUESS JUST
A COMMENT- MILLER WEEDS THE
STAFF PUTS FORTH A LOT OF EFFORT
IN. THESE BACKGROUND PAPERS IN
THE SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS AND
THEN THE ISSUES MANY ISSUES THAT
THEY HAS TO BE ADDRESSED SO.
APPS IN THE FUTURE WE COULD HAVE
A MORE ROBUST- RESPONSIBILITY
AND IN LOOKING AT IT IF YOU SEE
HOLES IN THE RESPONSE THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY FILED PERHAPS YOU
COULD SORT OF. FLUSH IT OUT FOR
US THAT MAKES SENSE YES IT DOES
IT WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO ADDRESS
ANY OF THOSE NOW THE MILITARY
ONE OR- THE AUDITOR PAST ISSUES
NOT NOT NECESSARILY I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD PREFER THAT I
MOVE ON BUT I WOULD LIKE. I
WOULD LIKE IT AND APPRECIATED IF
YOU WOULD SUBMIT THOSE THAT
ADDITIONAL DATA TO THE STAFF OF
BOTH COMMITTEES WHEN YOU HAVE A
CHANCE. THANK YOU PERFECT.
SENATOR PAN. FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU AND- YEAH.
OSTENTATION I DID NOT FOLLOW UP
ON ISSUE ONE AND I KNOW THAT HE
ANSWERED SOME QUESTIONS FROM
SENATOR FROM. SELLER BERMAN- YOU
KNOW IT THE R. A. BASICALLY I
THINK THE MAIN ANSWER YOU GAVE
WAS WELL WE'RE LOOKING AT
INCREASING OUR FEES AGAIN AND
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT MAYBE
YOU DON'T HAVE MANY OTHER
OPTIONS BUT- AGAIN I DO WANT TO.
POINT OUT AND I KNOW THE FASTEST
OF OTHER BOARDS. YEAH WHAT'S THE
IMPACT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S FEE INCREASES ON YOUR
YOUR FINANCIALS- AND THEN WE'VE
ALSO TALKED ABOUT SUCH ON THE
DCA PROGRAM THE COST. GOING UP
AS WELL. AND I WOULD MAKE NOTE
AGAIN THAT- YOU KNOW THESE THESE
FEE INCREASES OUR BURDENS ON THE
ON THE ON THE PROFESSIONALS-
PROVIDING SERVICES AND WILL
CERTAINLY IN A SENSE THAT
LICENSING FEE SHOULD. SUPPORT
THE COST OF- OF THE LICENSING
ACTIVITY- I THINK WE REALLY ALSO
NEED TO SCRUTINIZE WHEN
LICENSING BOARDS ARE BEING
CHARGED BY OTHER AGENCIES ARE
THOSE CHARGES IN LINE WITH THE
ACTUAL COSTS OR THEY ACTUALLY
END UP BEING FUND TRANSFERS.
FROM FROM FROM BASICALLY
LICENSEES TO SUPPORT OTHER
AGENCIES. AND AGAIN I WOULD JUST
MAKE NOTE I KEEP THAT RIGHT BUT
IN REGARDS TO SOME OF THE DOJ
COSTS THAT. NO WE'RE WE'RE
PAYING WE CAN ACTUALLY LOOK UP
FROM COLLEGE ARE WHAT THE SALARY
IS OF DIFFERENT- PROFESSIONALS
LAWYERS LEGAL YOU KNOW LEGAL
AIDES AT CETERA. AND YET WE
CALCULATE THE FEES AND YOU
FIGURE OUT THE HOURLY RATE AND
MATH. I MEAN THE ACTUAL CHARGES
MANY FULL THAT NIGHT I REALIZE
THERE MAY BE SOME ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS OR OTHER TYPES OF THINGS
BUT THERE'S A THERE'S A HUGE
DIFFERENCE AND THAT IS ALL NOW
BEING BORNE BY. THE LICENSEES
AND WE'VE ALSO HEARD OF COURSE
OTHER EXAMPLES WHERE- YOU KNOW
WHETHER IT'S A LAWSUIT OR OTHER
TYPES OF THINGS WHERE. IT'S NOT
THE FAULT THE LICENSEE YET THE
LICENSEES BEARING THE COST THE
JUST BEING PASSED ON TO
LICENSEES. SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION AND MAYBE IT'S NOT SO
MUCH A QUESTION YOU CAN ANSWER
IS THAT IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT
YOUR STRUCTURAL DEFICIT- IS THAT
WHAT. WHAT THE WHAT THE WHAT IS
YOUR BOARD SEE IN TERMS OF THE
ADDITIONAL BURDENS BEING PLACED
JUST BECAUSE OF THESE YOU KNOW
FEEDING THESE INCREASES THE
CHARGES TO YOU. BY DOJ ARE R. D.
C. A. AND ARE YOU LOOKING AT
WAYS TO BETTER ME. YOU USED TO
THOSE LEGAL SERVICES SO FORTH
TRY TO REDUCE THE COST ON THE
LICENSEES. AND TERMS OF MANAGING
IT AND THEN CERTAINLY I THINK
IT'S OUR ROLE TO PERHAPS ASKING
QUESTIONS AND- SAY THAT IS THIS
A REASONABLE CHARGE TO BE PASSED
ON TO LICENSEES. YEAH I THINK I
SHOULD ALSO MAY NOTICE IS THAT
THERE'S A LICENSEE MYSELF AND
ANOTHER BOARD. THAT YOU KNOW IT
DID AT LEAST AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL- WHEN THEY PASSED IT. THE
REPUBLICAN CONGRESS PASSED THE
TAX TAX CHANGES- YOU KNOW WE CAN
NO LONGER DEDUCT LICENSING FEES
AS PART OF OUR OUR IN INDIA.
WHERE TAXIS AND NOW ALSO IN OUR
OFFER INCOME TAX SO- IF YOU'RE
IF YOU'RE WORKING YOU KNOW YOU
CAN'T DEDUCT AS EXPENSES ANYMORE
SO THAT'S SORT OF ANOTHER
PERSONAL FEEDING TREES. TO YOUR
OWN PERSONAL FINANCES YOU PUT A
REPAIR FOR YOUR LICENSE. SO SO
AGAIN JUST HAVING THESE LICENSE
FEES GO UP AND UP AND UP WITHOUT
MORE RATIONALE THIS IS CERTAINLY
VERY CONCERNING. SO PERHAPS- CAN
YOU JUST MAYBE BRIEFLY TOUCH ON
WHAT IS THE BOARD TRYING TO DO
TERMS OF MANAGING THE- ROTATED
DEGREE LET'S SAY THE DOJ COSTS
AND TRYING TO LIMIT THE AMOUNT
OF- SERVICES YOU NEED TO. USE
YOUR YOU NEED TO USE SOME DOJ TO
TRY TO MATCH THE DECREASE THE-
IMPACT OF THOSE FEE INCREASES.
IT SENATOR. ON IF I IF I MAY
RESPOND TO THAT. IN TERMS OF THE
DOJ. COST INCREASES- ONBOARD HAS
LITTLE CONTROL OVER THAT WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT CERTAINLY- A
COMMUNICATION UP FRONT AND A
LITTLE BIT MORE IN ADVANCE I
WOULD HAVE BEEN YOU KNOW BETTER
FOR BOARD. OPERATIONS AS
MENTIONED IN THE PREVIOUS
HEARINGS WE DO HAVE A MECHANISM
TO INCREASE. OUR REQUEST AN
INCREASE IN- THOSE PARTICULAR
LINE ITEMS IN SO FAR AS IF WE-
ARE GETTING TO THE MAX. I'M IN
TERMS OF MANAGING IT. THE BOARD
REALLY DOES TAKE A CAREFUL LOOK
AT- DETERMINING WHETHER OR NOT.
A VIOLATION REACHES THE LEVEL OF
REQUIRING. THAT CASE BE REFERRED
TO THE AG'S OFFICE OR IF IT'S
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE HANDED
PENDULUM INDUSTRY. FOR EXAMPLE
BY ISSUING A CITATION FINE- IN
TERMS OF THE FEES- AND LOOKING
AT. THIS THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS ABOARD ASSET- A SUB
COMMITTEE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
ISSUE- THE BOARD DID VIEW. THE
CURRENT APPLICATION AND RENEWAL
FEES RELATIVE TO MANY OTHER
HEALTH CARE. BOARDS AND
CERTAINLY THIS BOARD IS CHARGING
LOWER FEES. LOWER THAN MOST-
ALSO EVEN IN TERMS OF-
ASSOCIATION MEMBERSHIPS THAT THE
BOARD'S LICENSING RENEWAL FEE
AND APPLICATION FEES. ARE YOU
KNOW ARE ALSO. LESS THE BOARD
DOES RECOGNIZE THE BURDEN TO THE
LICENSEES WHEN THERE IS ANY
PROSPECTIVE APPLICANTS WHEN
THERE ARE INCREASES IN THOSE
FEES. WHICH IS WHY THE BOARD IS
ALSO LOOKING AT A VARIETY OF
FEES- THAT COULD POSSIBLY BE
ADDRESSED FOR EXAMPLE
INCREASING- AN APPLICATION FEE
FROM FIFTY DOLLARS. TO SEVENTY
FIVE DOLLARS FOR EXAMPLE- THAT
MODEST INCREASE THOUGH. TO THE
APPLICANTS WOULD HAVE A BEARING
ON ALTERNATELY THE FEE NECESSARY
TO BE INCREASED FOR THE RENEWAL
FEE AN OPTION TO RENEW V. AS THE
PRIMARY- REVENUE SOURCE. THE
BOARD. DOES FEEL THAT WE'VE DONE
A GOOD JOB. MANAGING BUDGETS
JUST- UNPLANNED- INCREASES AND
IN THE BOARD EVERY WE DID
PROVIDE. A TEN YEAR HISTORICAL
INFORMATION DEMONSTRATING
CONTINUED HER VERSION OF FUNDS
SO I THINK THAT IT'S NOT SO
MUCH- MAYBE A MANAGEMENT WE
OBSCENE CLOSELY MANAGE AND
MONITOR THE BOARD'S BUDGET. BUT
IT SIMPLY HISTORICALLY- UNDER
EARNING THE REVENUE NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT THOSE EXPENDITURES I
HOPE THAT'S BEEN RESPONSIVE TO
YOUR QUESTION. YES THANK YOU AND
AGAIN I SAID WE ALSO HAVE OUR
TASK HERE TOO BECAUSE SAID
YOU'RE TOLD THESE FEES WE NEED
TO BE ASKING QUESTIONS ACROSS
THE BOARD ACROSS THE BOARDS.
ABOUT WHY IS IT THAT- THEY'RE
BEING CHARGED SO MUCH AND IS
THAT REALLY THE ACTUAL COSTS TO
THE DOJ FOR PROVIDING THE
SERVICES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR PENCE CIRCULAR YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE- OCULAR
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY ACT
OBVIOUSLY- PERTAINS TO
INVESTIGATION AND POTENTIAL
FRAUD IN LOT OF ISSUES MY
CONCERN IS ARE YOU FINDING THAT
THERE'S PEOPLE THAT ARE OUTSIDE
YOUR INDUSTRY WHO ARE PRACTICING
IN THE INDUSTRY CAUSING AN ISSUE
CONSUMER COMPLAINT WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH THAT ARE YOU- RECEIVING
COMPLAINTS AND ARE YOU ACTING
UPON. THANK YOU SENATOR
ARCHULETA- ACTUALLY WORK WE ARE
FORTUNATE WITH- LICENSURE- YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEEN AROUND TWENTY
YEARS WHICH COMPARED TO MOST
HEALTH CARE BOARD YOU KNOW IS A
VERY LONG- WE ARE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH THOUGH THAT THE
UNLICENSED PRACTICE BY
INDIVIDUALS IS NOT REALLY AN
ISSUE FOR THIS COURT- YOU KNOW I
DON'T HAVE QUITE FRANKLY.
LICENSEES PRACTICING ON AN
EXPIRED LICENSE IS A MORE
COMMON- VIOLATION IF YOU WILL
THAN OTHER INDIVIDUALS
PRACTICING OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
WERE NOT AUTHORIZED TO DO SO.
DOES DOES THAT ADDRESS YOUR
QUESTION. YES IT DOES THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU SENATOR I
SEE NO OTHER MONKS UP SO LET'S
TURN TO TESTIMONY FROM MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY. FIRST WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. I SEE NO SUCH
WITNESSES. THAT'S TURNED
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
FEUD PLEASE PROMPT ANY SUCH
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. WE WILL CONTINUE.
PLEASE GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON THE LEGISLATION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. YOU JUST MIGHT HAVE
SOMEBODY COMING UP.
WE'LL START WITH ONE NUMBER
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DR
MEMBER MINUTE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WANT TO BE CALLED THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA. AND THANK YOU FOR
THE DISCUSSION TODAY AND WANT TO
KNOW THAT WE ARE VERY IMPORTANT
AND THE CONTINUATION OF THE
COURT OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY WHICH
YOU KNOW PLAYS. A CRITICAL ROLE
IN OVERSIGHT AND OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY TRAINING AT
PRACTITIONERS AND THE PROTECTION
OF THE ASIAN- THE- ACCORDING THE
CONNECTICUT NOT AFFORD TO. I
LIKE HEARING. A COMMITTEE TODAY
THEY'VE DISCUSSED AND THINK IT
IS GREAT BUT I JUST LIKE TO
REGARD OUR ISSUES AND CONCERNS
FIRST NARCOTICS NUMBER ONE. AND
THE FOUR LOOKING INTO POTENTIAL
INCREASES CRIME. THERAPY I THINK
YOU. CAN PROBABLY UNDERSTAND THE
NEED TO. PUBLICLY AND WE DON'T
WANT THAT AND YOU KNOW IT BACK.
THE THING I CAN THINK OF
ALREADY. BURDEN FOR MANY OF THE
PACKAGE CALIFORNIA. AND THE
BIENNIAL LATELY THE REALTY WHEN
I. HEAR IF YOU HEARD. WHAT
HAPPENED ONE THING SURE TO ANY
BECAUSE THE INCREASE IN THEIR
NAME AND QUICKLY. AND EITHER
AVENUE AND EXPENDITURE
REDUCTIONS THERE TOWARD THE
PHONE THESE ARE INCREASED. ONE
SECOND I THINK I WANT TO GET
FRESH LOOK PERFECT IF YOU NUMBER
THREE. ALL THE PACKAGE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF ADDING. SOMETHING
PRACTITIONER FOR THE MOSCOW NOT
BACK. AND BASICALLY ALLOWING IT
PROFESSIONAL CORPORATION AND FOR
THE EMPLOYEES OR SHAREHOLDERS
UNDER MEDICAL CORPORATION. PLANS
OVER THE YEARS A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT HEALING ARE QUITE
HIGH. I THINK THAT COULD BE
GIVEN THE AUTHORITY INCLUDING
PHYSICIANS PSYCHOLOGISTS SPEECH
LANGUAGE PATHOLOGISTS AND
PHYSICAL THERAPIST AMONG MANY
OTHERS. AND ALTHOUGH IT'S EITHER
CURRENTLYCOMMITTED HE SHOT
SHAREHOLDERS UNDER. PHYSICAL
THERAPY CORPORATIONS THEY CAN'T
.
AT THAT. AND WE BELIEVE IT'S A
NON CONTROVERSIAL CHANGE AND
YOU'RE NOT AWARE OF. ANY
OPPOSITION TO IT THAT WE WOULD
URGE. THE LEGISLATURE TO CLARIFY
A LOT QUICKER MAY HELP KEEP IT
ON THEIR OWN POTENTIAL
CORPORATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE. WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN QUEUE AT
THE TIME. PERFECT. WE'VE HEARD
ALL THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY NOW-
MEMBERS ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS I
SEE NO MIKE'S UP LET'S NOW MOVE
TO OUR FINAL BOARD WHICH IS THE
PHYSICAL THERAPY BOARD
CALIFORNIA WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
DR LOUIS YOU RUBINA AMEND BOARD
PRESIDENT TONYA MCMILLAN BOARD
VICE PRESIDENT AND JASON KAISER
EXECUTIVE OFFICER PANELISTS
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD MORNING
HONORABLE CHAIRS ROCKS AND
BOURBON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT OUR
SUNSET THE REPORT TODAY. MY NAME
IS DR RICHARD DEAN INMAN AND I'M
A LICENSED BOARD MEMBER
CURRENTLY SERVING AS A BOARD
PRESIDENT OF IS WHAT THEIR-REPORT CALIFORNIA WITH THE P. T.
V. C. WITH ME TODAY IS BOARD
MEMBER TOM IN THE MILLIONS. THE
SERVICE IS A PUBLIC MEMBER OF
THE MARTIN IS CURRENTLY SERVING
AS A VICE PRESIDENT. ALSO WITH
ME AS MR JASON KAISER WHOSE.
SECOND OFFICER D. THE PHYSICAL
THERE PRACTICE ACT WITH INSTEAD
IN NINETEEN FIFTY THREE WAR DOES
COME. OF SEVEN MEMBERS FOR
GOVERNOR APPOINTED PROFESSIONAL
MEMBERS ONE GOVERNOR APPOINTED
PUBLIC NUMBER. ONE SENATE
APPOINTED PUBLIC MEMBER AND ONE
ASSEMBLY APPOINTED PUBLIC
MEMBERS. OR THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY VACANCY. THE MISSION OF THE
PHYSICAL THERAPY BOARD IS TO
ENHANCE AND PROTECT THE
INTERESTS OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT THE EFFECTIVE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PHYSICAL
THERAPY PRACTICE ASKED. WHAT
OVERSEAS MARKETS SIX THOUSAND
LICENSEES OVER THIRTY SIX P. T.
AND PTA PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. IN ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE DID YOU KNOW YOU
COMPETENCY APPROVAL AGENCY. BBC
ALSO TAKES ENFORCEMENT OF
UNFORTUNATE ACTION UPON THE
LICENSEE LICENSOR INDIVIDUALS.
WHO VIOLATE OUR PRACTICE AFTER.
DURING BOARD MEETINGS OUR BOARD
MEMBERS OFTEN REMIND EACH OTHER
THAT WE EXIST TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. WE ARE ALSO EVER
COGNIZANT OF THE IMPORTANT AND
DIVERSE PERSPECTIVES THAT
LICENSED BOARD MEMBERS AND
PUBLIC BOARD MEMBERS ADD TO
ENRICH OUR DELIBERATIONS IN OUR
DECISION MAKING. WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE VICE PRESIDENT
PUBLIC MEMBER TIME TO GO. THANK
YOU. FOLLOWING OUR LAST SUNRISE
TWO NEW BOARD MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED TO REPLACE THE TWO
OUTGOING THAT. ARE OUTSTANDING
EXECUTIVE OFFICER LEADERSHIP
UNDER MISTER KEISER REMAINS THE
SAME HE HAS LED STAFF SUPPORTER
SUPPORTED WE AND EFFICIENTLY-
THE PANDEMIC INCLUDING I MOVED
TO A LOCATION FROM LARGER
SWEETS. THERE ARE BEEN NO SEE
INCREASES SINCE OUR LAST SUNSET
REVIEW AND MR KAISER CONTINUES
TO ACTIVELY BALANCE OUR BUDGET
WHICH IS SIX MILLION FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS WE HAVE A LITTLE OVER
TEN MONTHS RESERVE AND IT'S FUN.
FOR HER LAST. GRAND FORTY YEARS
AGO WE HAD DINNER FIVE GOALS
ENHANCE SERVICES FOR A. VARIETY
OF OUR STATE. WE ARE HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT THE FEW YEARS EACH
THROUGH THE EVENT IN. SAID IS
PRESENT OUR OPPORTUNITIES ALMOST
ALL THE P. T. M. B. T. EIGHT
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS PRESENTATIONS THE LICENSEE.
ANOTHER GOAL MET FROM
RESTAURANTS TO DO PLANT WAS
IMPROVING SERVICE TO APPLICANTS
BE ENDORSEMENTS FOR EDUCATED
PHYSICAL THERAPIST AND MILITARY
PERSONNEL AS WELL AS THEIR
SPOUSES. WE NOW HAVE DEDICATED
STAFF AND PROCEDURES FOR
PROCESSING THESE APPLICATIONS
MORE EFFICIENT EFFICIENTLY AND
I'D LIKE TO HAND IT OVER TO OUR
EMAIL. LIST HIGHS. BUT ACTUALLY
REMEMBERS- ESTIMATE OF THIS
PROGRAM ON THE STOCK BOARD I
JUST LIKE TO THINK WE ARE TO
STAMP THIS REVIEW- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND TO BE RESPECTED
BUT MAYBE SOMTIME WE'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU SIR. CALLINGS QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS MISTER
RICHARD BERMAN IF HE HAS ANY.
MIKE THANK YOU GERMAN ROTH
BRIDGET THANK YOU FOR THE- THE
VERY GOOD AND CONCISE
PRESENTATIONS JUST A QUICK
QUESTION I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S A DESIRE TO INCREASE
THE- STATUTORY CAPS SO THAT WHEN
NECESSARY- YOU HAVE THE ABILITY
TO INCREASE FEES IN TERMS OF THE
BOARD'S REQUESTS- WHAT STEPS
WITH THE BOARD TAKE WHEN
INCREASING FEES AND REGULATIONS
AND WHAT WITH THE AUDIT AND
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT LOOK
LIKE. WERE THAT TO HAPPEN. YES
WE DO- WE INTEND TO BE PROACTIVE
WHEN WE CAN'T AND SO I'M GONNA
LET YOU. EXECUTIVE VICE OFFICER
KAISER INTO THAT QUESTION. SHE
JUST BE VERY CLEAR. WORDS NOT-
ASKING WE NEED TO SECURE THE
INCREASE THIS TIME AS GERMAN
BIRMINGHAM STATED WHAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR IS INCREASE THE
STATUTORY CAPS JUST IN. THE
EVENT THAT THERE ARE ANY KIND OF
UNFORESEEN EXPENDITURES THAT
MIGHT HAPPEN JUST REPAIRING FOR.
THE WORST OF ALL OUTCOMES SO-
JUST FEATURE PROCESS BALANCE
ELSON WAS JUST BY THE
REGULATIONS FOR PROM DATES YOU
WOULD GO THROUGH A VERY LENGTHY
PROCESS- DOES STAKEHOLDER
FEEDBACK. OUR LICENSEES ARE
PROFESSIONALS ASSOCIATION IN THE
CONSUMERS WOULD BE ABLE TO FIND
FEEDBACK NOT PROCESS. PRIOR TO
THAT WE HAVE TO DO IS JUST. WHAT
THE INCREASE WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE YOU KNOW GIVEN THE
BOARD'S FINANCIAL SITUATION-
AGAIN. LOOKING AT FINALLY THIS
STATES TODAY. I'M USING
CONCERNED ESTIMATE WE DO SEE. AN
INCREASE IN EXPENDITURE OUT.
LINING IN REVENUE OUR PROJECT-
INSOLVENCY RATE FOR FISCAL YEARS
FROM NOW- AND SO THAT THAT
STATUTORY CAP IS IMPORTANT TO US
BECAUSE WE WOULD LIKE. TO BE AS
FAR OFF AS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU
AND I GUESS. ONE MORE QUESTION
ARE REALLY JUST AN OPENING TO
LET YOU YOU KNOW DISCUSS IT IF
YOU LIKE BUT- I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE A LIMITATION ON. HOW OFTEN
A PATIENT CAN SEE THE PHYSICAL
THERAPIST BEFORE POSITION NEEDS
TO PHYSICALLY EXAMINE THE
PATIENT. AND SIGN OFF ON
CONTINUE TREATMENT I KNOW THAT
THIS WAS WAVE DURING THE
PANDEMIC- AND THAT THERE IS A
DESIRE TO SEE THAT MADE
PERMANENT WOULD YOU LIKE TO TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT ISSUE.
YES SO- THAT WAIVER ALLOWED FOR
A TELEHEALTH VISIT WOULD
POSITION. AND THE PATIENCE OF A
FACE TO FACE VISIT AND WE DO
FEEL LIKE THAT SHOULD CONTINUE
INDEFINITELY SO OVER THE
PANDEMIC THE MODEL WORKS VERY
WELL WITH PHYSICAL THERAPIST
STILL REFERRING PATIENTS BACK TO
THEIR DOCTORS THE STUFF FACE TO
FACE VISITS. WHEN THAT WAS
NECESSARY WITH THE PRACTITIONER
FELT LIKE THE PATIENT DID NEED
TO SEE THEIR DOCTOR BUT IN ORDER
JUST TO CONTINUE THE SERVICES
AND YOU A DELAY IN SERVICES I
THINK THAT I'M CONTINUING THIS
TELEHEALTH IS IT COULD BE VERY.
BENEFICIAL TO PATIENT CARE. YOU
CAN ADD. YOU KNOW THE ONLY THING
I WOULD ASK THAT IF SOMEONE OR
JUST A MODERNIZATION APPROACH
RIGHT SO WHEN THOSE STATUTES
WRITTEN- TELEMEDICINE WAS IN ITS
INFANCY AND NOW I THINK WITH OUR
EXPERIENCES STRUGGLE
ACADEMICALLY REALIZED THEY CAN
WORK VERY WELL- AND WE WOULD
STILL BE RELYING ON SPECIAL BOTH
PRACTITIONERS IN THE MATTER AND
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S APPROPRIATE
BUT I THINK JUST REMOVING THE
WORDS IN PERSON FROM THAT
PARTICULAR. STATUTE WILL SOLVE
OUR PROBLEMS. THE YOU. RICHARD
BERMAN- LET ME JUST ASK A QUICK
QUESTION BEFORE I MOVED TO
SENATOR ARCH ALETTA. YEAH I'M
LOOKING AT THE BACKGROUND PAPER
AND THEN I THINK- SURE BERMAN
WAS REFERENCING THIS WHEN HE
ASKED HIS QUESTION ABOUT THE
STATUTORY CAP BUT THE-
BACKGROUND PAPER TALKS ABOUT A
DIMINISHING FINE CONDITIONS
STARTING IN. FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
CONTINUING EACH FISCAL YEAR WITH
THE PROJECTED INSOLVENCY.
OCCURRING IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX WELL
WE'RE IN. PLANNING FOR FISCAL
pTWENTY THREE RIGHT NOW IT
DOESN'T SEEM THAT FAR OFF I
HAVEN'T. I HEARD A PLAN IS THERE
A PLAN OR IS THE PLAN JUST
INCREASE THE STATUTORY CAP AND
WE'LL FIGURE THIS OUT LATER.
I'LL TAKE THAT QUESTION- THANK
YOU FOR ASKING IT BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S JUST AN OPPORTUNITY
TO KIND OF EXPRESS AGAIN THAT
CONCERN- THIS WAR IS BEEN VERY
PHYSICALLY RESPONSIBLE. ROBERT
AND ANNA CAN PRIOR I'M VERY
MINDFUL OF MONIES THAT WE START
OF OUR LICENSEES- YES CONTINUE
TO RISE AND THIS WORD ESPECIALLY
CONTINUES TO GROW AS THE
PRESSURE GROWS THERE IS A LITTLE
BIT OF A GROWING PAIN IN THE
SENSE THAT WE ARE STILL TRYING
TO CATCH UP BASH- AS AN EXAMPLE
THE NUMBER OF PTA PROGRAMS HAS
INCREASED SINCE OUR LAST ANSWER
SIXTEEN PROGRAMS NOW TWENTY TWO-
AND WITH THAT COMES AN INCREASE
IN APPLICATIONS RECEIVED THE
LICENSES ISSUED AND SO ON- WE DO
IT WE CAN'T CONTROL COSTS
INSIDE. REALLY REALLY- GOOD JOB
CONSIDERING WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
A HELP ME FIND THE DISHES ARE
LAST FEW GREASE- WE PUT MONEY
AWAY FOR A MOVE TO A LARGER
SWEET- ALL WHILE. ALSO REGARDING
MY RESPECT FOR FUN. I'M I WILL
SAY THE FUND ISSUE- FOR
EXPENDITURES SOMETHING WE CAN
RUN ON THEIR TRAIN THAT ARE IN.
YOU KNOW THROUGH ECONOMICS AND
SAY. OUR COSTS ARE GOING TO GO
UP ONE YEAR TO THE NEXT FIGHT.
AGAIN PERCENTAGE. OUR
PROJECTIONS ARE REVENUES ARE
VERY CONSERVATIVE IN THE SENSE
THEIR BASELINE FROM ACTUAL REAL
NUMBERS- AND WHILE I KNOW THAT
OUR LICENSE VIOLATION IS GROWING
ACTUALLY. SOME INCREASE IN OUR
REVENUES RECEIVED A GENERALIZED.
RIGHT FROM- VERY TRUE JENNIFER
STARTED I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE BOUNCING. THE SPORTS BUT
SHE'S THE BEST PART. WHAT I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR ATTEMPTING TO
MANAGE YOUR FINANCES THE BOARD'S
FINANCES. AS WELL AS YOU HAVE
AND CAN DO THE FOLKS IN THE
HORSE YOU HAVE HEARD ME SAY THIS
BEFORE I'M NOT SURE. THAT IT'S
TOTALLY APPROPRIATE TO FOIST THE
ENTIRE COST OF GOVERNMENT. ON
THOSE WHO ARE LICENSED IN
OCCUPATIONS AND PROFESSIONS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I THINK
THERE'S A PLACE FOR. LICENSEES
TO PAY FOR A CERTAIN PORTION OF
THE COST OF GOVERNMENT THAT ARE
DIRECTLY ATTRIBUTED. TO THEIR
ACTIVITIES IS LICENSEES BUT I'M
NOT SURE THAT. THAT THE ENTIRE
COST FOR EXAMPLE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
SHOULD BE FUNDED BY. THOSE WHO
AR LICENSED IN PROFESSIONS AND
OCCUPATIONS IN CALIFORNIA I MAY
BE ONE VOICE OUT OF A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE BUT- THE FACT
OF THE MATTER IS. TODAY I GET TO
CURE THIS THE COMMITTEE AND I
GET TO EXPRESS THAT OPINION I
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING
I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR PLAN I'D
LIKE TO SEE YOU AVOID- FINANCIAL
INSOLVENCY BECAUSE- IF YOUR DOG
WILL YOU'LL JUST. JOIN THE LONG.
STORY LINE OF BOARDS. BUREAUS
AND COMMITTEES THAT ARE FARTHER
FACING FINANCIAL INSOLVENCY OR
THAT ARE ALREADY HERE THERE AND
I JUST ASSUME THAT IT TO THE
LIST. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEARCH A LOT OF. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR. OF MY QUESTION PERTAINS
TO OUR MILITARY VETERANS. WHO
HAVE SERVED OUR GREAT COUNTRY
AND WHO HAVE- OBTAIN KNOWLEDGE
AND SKILL. ESPECIALLY OUR MEDICS
AS YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD. VETERANS
WHO HAVE- COME INTO THE CIVILIAN
WORLD- WITH EXPERTISE AND I WILL
POINT OUT. THAT WITH THE NUMBER
OF INJURIES WE'VE HAD IN
AFGHANISTAN IRAQ OVER THE YEARS.
THESE EXPERTS WHO HAVE THE-
MILITARY OCCUPATIONAL
SPECIALTIES TO HANDLE. AND WORK
WITH PATIENTS ESPECIALLY. WHEN
IT COMES TO GETTING THEM.
STRONGER AND UP TO- THE ABILITY
TO WALK AGAIN AND PHYSICAL
THERAPY. IS THEIR EXPERTISE.
HAVE YOU DECIDED AND IF YOU
LOOKED INTO OPENING UP YOUR- GET
INDUSTRY TO THESE VETERANS AND-
AND GETTING THEM- INVOLVED IN A
PATHWAY. TO BE CERTIFIED AND
LICENSED IN SHOW ON. TO JOIN
YOUR RANKS WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT. AS I MENTIONED
A LITTLE EARLIER WE DO HAVE A
STAFF MEMBER. BASICALLY ASSIGNED
TO MILITARY APPLICATIONS AND
PROCESSING THOSE- MILITARY
MEMBERS AS WELL AS THEIR SPOUSE
AND ALL THAT MR PAGER ANSWERS
THE QUESTION ABOUT GETTING THEM
MORE INVOLVED. YES THANK YOU
SENATOR OURS WERE QUESTION- WE
FEEL ABOUT OUR VETERANS VERY
MUCH SAME WAY YOU DO- AND
LUCKILY FOR US THE MILITARY
DOES- REQUIRE THE SAME MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE NEED
CALIFORNIA STATE LICENSURE SO
IT'S VERY EASY FOR MILITARY
VETERANS TO. THE CALIFORNIA TO
PRACTICE YOUR POST RETIREMENT OR
DISCHARGE- AND AS- DOCTOR
MEETING AND STATED WE HAVE
DOESN'T EVEN STAFF WHEN I SAY
DOESN'T IT STOP I WANT TO LEAVE
THE IMPRESSION THAT. WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO DO WHAT OUR
MISSION IS TO PROVIDE CONCIERGE
LEVEL SERVICES TO OUR MILITARY
VETERANS AND THEIR SPOUSES I
MEAN YOU JUST STEPPED OUT FOR
YOU- THAT THE APPLICATION
PROCESS CAN BE QUITE COMPLEX. WE
WANT TO HELP THEM WITH THAT
PROCESS AND GET THEM YOU KNOW
ACCLIMATED TO THE. STATE AND
NATIONAL SCRIPT RESPONSE. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR. SEEING NO OTHER MIKES
LET'S TURN TO TESTIMONY FROM
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
PHYSICAL THERAPY BOARD FIRST
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NO SUCH WITNESSES MODERATOR FEUD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT ABOUT THE
PHYSICAL THERAPY BOARD. WE WILL
CONTINUE. IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
ON THIS LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND YOU'RE AT THE TIME. YOU
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SENATOR ROTH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BURMA MEMBERS- THIS IS- CALLED
LONDON HERE TO PROVIDE COMMENTS
ON THE P. T. BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
SUNSET REVIEW REPORT- CPT EIGHT
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY SUPPORTS.
THE CONTINUATION OF HIS PHYSICAL
THERAPY FOR CALIFORNIA'S THE
PRIMARY MEANS OF. ZIMMER
PROTECTION REGULARLY REGARDING
THE PROFESSION IN OUR OPINION B.
PORT REPRESENTS THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS YOU COULD POSSIBLY
CHEAP FOR A LICENSING BOARD. THE
BOARD IS A VERY CLEAR MISSION TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS THE PHYSICAL
THERAPY SERVICES THEY'RE VERY
TRANSPARENT THEIR ACTIVITIES IN
THE YOU SEE THEM AS A GOOD
STEWARD. OF THE FEES COLLECTED
FROM LICENSEES THAT WILL ADD
THIS DOES NOT MEAN BY THE WAY
THAT THEY ALWAYS AGREE WITH US-
LAUGHING SAY IS THAT- CPJ'S. THE
BOARD'S RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
LEGISLATIVE REGULAR CHANGES
REGULATORY CHANGES TO THE- TO
THE PRACTICE ACT CONTAINED IN
THE REPORT. WE'VE SPECIALLY
SUPPORT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING- THE IDEA OF MAKING
PERMANENT THE IN PERSON EXAM
WAIVER FOR DIRECT ACCESS
TREATMENTS BUT PHYSICAL
THERAPIST. IT WAS PUT IN PLACE
IN THE COPA NINETY PANDEMIC
RULES. THIS WEEK DO YOU BELIEVE
WOULD PROVIDE GREATER ACCESS ON
AN ONGOING BASIS TO CARE FOR
PHYSICAL THERAPY CONSUMERS.
EFFICIENCY WHILE MAINTAINING
APPROPRIATE CONSUMER PROTECTION.
OVERALL AGAIN JUST WANT TO
COMMEND THE WORK FOR ITS PAST
PRESENT EFFORTS. AND WE HOPE THE
COMMITTEES TO SEE FIT TO ALLOW.
THIS BOARD TO CONTINUE ON ITS
PRESENT FORM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SIR. MODERATOR
NEXT PLEASE. WE HAVE NO ENERGY
TO IT IN TIME EXCELLENT WE'VE
NEVER HEARD PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
MEMBERS ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. SAYING
NONE. WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE AND THE
SENATE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE AND OUR WITNESSES FOR
THEIR TESTIMONY TODAY I WOULD
LIKE TO ALSO THANK. MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC FOR SHARING STORIES
OF WEIGHING IN ON THESE
PARTICULAR PROCEEDINGS. IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR MISS PLEASE
SUBMIT OUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
OR- THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. OR VISIT
OUR RESPECTIVE WEBSITES YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE. THANK YOU WELL
WE APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
I SPECIFICALLY WANT TO. THANK MY
COLLEAGUES HERE BERMAN FOR HIS
PARTICIPATION AND COOPERATION IN
THE SCHEDULING IN THE CONDUCT OF
THESE HEARINGS WE HAVE NOW
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA. THE JOINT
SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT HEARING
OF TODAY IS NOW A JUROR.